bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat à suivre ce
matin en séance l'examen d'une
proposition de loi socialiste qui fait
du 19 mars une journée national du
souvenir de la guerre d'Algérie et des
combats en Tunisie et au Maroc un texte
à tras haute charge polémique qui
intervient quelques semaines avant le
déplacement de François Hollande en
Algérie la droite y voit une offense
faite à la mémoire des piedsnoirs des
arquis et des anciens combattants elle
regrette que l'examen du texte soit
devenu une séance de rempentant selon
les termes de Jean-Claude car sénateur
UMP de la Haute Savoie le gouvernement
lui est conscient de la passion avec
laquelle chaque camp défend sa position
et s'en remet à la sagesse de
l'hémicycle le texte a été voté à
l'Assemblée national il y a plus de 10
ans en janvier 2002 s'il est adopté
aujourd'hui sans modification il entrera
en vigueur 50 ans après la fin des
conflits tout de suite direction donc
l'hémicycle très bonne matinée à tous
sur Public
Sénat la séance est
ouverte le contterendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué il n'y
a pas
d'observation le procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves
d'usage je rappelle au Sénat que le
premier ministre a demandé au Sénat de
bien vouloir procéder à la désignation
du sénateur appelé à siéger au sein du
comité de préfiguration des modalités
d'instauration du profil biologique des
sportifs la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la Communication a
fait connaître qu'elle propose la
candidature de Monsieur Jean-Jacques
loszac pour siéger au sein de cet
organisme
extraparlementaire cette candidature a
été affichée et sera ratifiée
conformément à l'article 9 du règlement
s'il n'y a pas d'opposition à
l'expiration du délai d'une
heure monsieur le Président du Sénat a
reçu de Monsieur le 1emier Ministre le
rapport sur l'évaluation du coût réel
des dépenses supplémentaires engendré
par la retraite à raison de sa
pénibilité établi en application de
l'article 81 de la loi du 9 novembre
2010 portant réforme des
retraite il a également reçu le rapport
sur la situation du logement en France
en 2011 acte est donné du dépôt de ces
rapports le prier a été transmis à la
commission des affaires sociales le
second à la commission des affaires
économiques ils sont disponibles au
bureau de la
distribution je suis saisi d'un rappel
au règlement par Monsieur François Noël
buffet vous avez la parole monsieur
buffet merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues je voudrais faire ce
rappel au Règlement sur le fondement des
dispositions de l'article 29 TER de
notre règlement intérieur et et redire à
cette séance ce début de séance notre
regret pour ne pas dire pour ne pas dire
notre agacement quant au comportement
aujourd'hui du du gouvernement en effet
sur une décision unilatérale certes qui
lui appartient
constitutionnellement le gouvernement a
décidé de modifier l'organisation de nos
travaux pour les journées d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui inscrivant notamment dans
son ordre du jour une proposition de loi
relative au 19 mars dont l'examen a déjà
débuté dans un espace réservé du groupe
socialiste il est toujours d'ailleurs
intéressant de de rappeler quelques
faits antérieurs en effet il est pour le
moins surprenant que l'examen d'une
proposition de loi inscrite dans un
espace réservé à un groupe se poursuive
dans le cadre d'un ordre du jour
gouvernemental ou alors est-ce conforme
à l'esprit des institutions ou alors
cela revient à opérer de fait la
mutation d'une proposition de loi en
projet de loi sans qu'il a été procédé
pardon au préalable à une étude d'impact
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit cela je cite
simplement nos collègues repsamen et
carer qui ont tenu ces propos il y a pas
si longtemps que ça dans cette assemblée
alors je voudrais rappeler que il faut
un peu de mémoire mais ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui n'est plus la vérité d'hier
mais c'est vrai qu'une réclame que l'on
voit souvent à la télévision en ce
moment pour ch de lunette c'était avant
donc ça c'est clair nous avons donc
l'impression que il faudrait rajouter
tout de même que cette décision par
ailleurs a été prise le mercredi 31
octobre 31 octobre veille d'un weekend
prolongé tout le monde le sait n'a pas
été porté immédiatement à la
connaissance des sénateurs comme
l'impose l'alinéa 8 de l'article 29 B de
notre règlement puisque'une modification
de l'ordre du jour a seulement été
adressée par mail au groupes politique
sans lecture en séance publique avant la
modification du site public du Sénat dès
le 2 novembre voilà je vous demande donc
monsieur monsieur le Président de nous
faire de ouvert le porte-parole de de ce
que nous sommes en train de vous
expliquer auprès du président du Sénat
pour qu'il veille à ce que nous ne
soyons pas toujours au Sénat la chambre
du patinage alors que nous allons
prendre un chemin original et inhabituel
comme le disait si bien le président
belle en début de mandature
merci acte vous en est donné monsieur
buffet l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de la discussion de la proposition de
loi adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale
relative à la reconnaissance du 19 mars
comme journée nationale du souvenir et
de recueillement à la mémoire des
victimes civiles et militaires de la
guerre d'Algérie et des combats en
Tunisie et au Maroc dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur jean-clude Jean-Claude Carles
pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues 10 ans
après sa discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale la gauche ressort des limes de
l'histoire parlementaire la proposition
de loi relative au 19 mars 50 ans après
la signature des accords déviant la
gauche ne désarme pas à imposer coûte
que coûte le 19 mars je trouve cela
inopportun voire malsin comme si en ces
temps
le Parlement n'avait pas d'autres
priorités à traiter comme si notre pays
ne connaissait pas suffisamment de sujet
d'inquiétude pour le futur sans chercher
à se déchirer sur le passé comme si
depuis tout ce temps la France n'avait
pas reconnu la guerre d'Algérie pour ce
qu'elle fut et n'avait pas fixé une date
officielle celle du 5 décembre mais
c'était sans c'était compté sans un
calcul politique qui loin d'éclairer le
passé et d'apaiser les blessures de
l'histoire voudrait aujourd'hui les
raviver soit pour complaire à certaines
associations soit pour satisfaire à
quelques cerclle d'intellectuels
moralisateurs prompt à réécrire
l'histoire et à se souvenir des uns pour
me oublier les autres soit encore pour
donner des gages à une partie de votre
majorité afin d'obtenir son vote lors de
prochain scrutin qui s'avère délicat je
n'ose pas le croire
à moins qu'il s'agisse enfin de donner
des gages à certains interlocuteurs à
des fins étrangères au sujet qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui quitte là aussi à
faire de la repentance un ousi de la
diplomatie quand ce n'est pas tout
simplement osons le dire une marque de
faiblesse je le craignais lors de la
discussion du texte du 25 octobre
dernier j'en suis aujourd'hui convaincu
ne serait-ce que parce que le
gouvernement l'a inscrit dans son espace
réservé alors que ce même 25 octobre
vous concluiez vos propos monsieur le
ministre en en affirmant vouloir laisser
le Sénat débattre en toute sagesse et je
vous cite sans aucune ingérence ni
interférence de la part de l'exécutif
propos que vous avez d'ailleurs réitéré
ce lundi à l'Assemblée nationale lors du
vote du budget des anciens combattants
serae mes chers collègues un nouveau CAK
et bien non nous n'avons pas a joué les
porteurs de valises de l'histoire
monsieur
monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur cher
Alain nry qui était député qui était
député en 2002 et et avait mes chers
collègues et avait alors voté la
proposition de loi peut bien nous
assurer de sa bonne foi en affirmement
et je vous cite le 19 mars doit apaiser
et rassembler en permettant de se
souvenir de tous les morts avant et
après cette date comme on le fait pour
le 11 novembre et le 8 mai pour les deux
guerres comparer le 19 mars 1962 avec le
11 novembre 1918 et le 8 mai 45 je ne
m'y risquerai pas si la reconnaissance
de l'état de guerre en Algérie avait été
adoptée à l'unanimité par l'Assemblée
nationale il n'en sera pas de même pour
le 19 mars qui pour nombre d'anciens
combattants d'appeler du contingent de
rapatrier de qui est à jamais le symbole
d'une défaite et d'un abandon si la
majorité de gauche avait adopté une
proposition de loi en 2002 à l'Assemblée
nationale il est tout de même important
de nous rappeler que Monsieur Jospin
n'avait pas accepté qu'elle soit ensuite
débatue au Sénat estimant à l'époque
qu'il n'y avait pas de consensus de même
en 1981 le président de la République
François mitteran déclarait si une date
doit être officialisée pour célébrer le
souvenir des victimes de la guerre
Algérie cela ne peut pas être le 19 mars
car il y aura confusion dans la mémoire
de notre peuple et d'ajouter il convient
de ne froisser la conscience de personne
si la date du 19 mars revient depuis tel
un slogan dans les revendications de
certaines associations d'autres
associations d'anciens combattants tout
aussi légitimes et tout aussi nombreuses
et qui aujourd'hui manifeste ont dit
clairement leur opposition preuve que
nous sommes bien loin de l'apaisement et
du
rassemblement comment pourrait-il en
être autrement quand la République
Algérienne émet un timbre en souvenir du
19 mars sur lequel est portée la mention
faite de la victoire comment pourrait-il
en être autrement quand le président
boutficaa en visite dans notre pays se
livrant à une comparaison avec les
heures sombres de l'occupation en France
déclare que aux yeux de l'opinion
publique de son pays l'éarchie étit des
collabos sans que le gouvernement
français d'alors dirigé par Monsieur
Jospin réagisse comment pourrait-il en
être autrement quand Monsieur Hollande
évoque la répression des Algériens le 17
octobre 1961 et rend hommage à la
mémoire des victimes soit mais sans un
mot pour les policiers français tués ou
blessés dans les attentats perpétrés
contre eux par le FLN ni ni pour les
Algériens raquettés et violenté par ce
même mes chers collègues croyez-vous mes
chers collègues
croyez-vous que les formations
politiques qui à gauche avaient voté les
pouvoirs spéciaux au président du
conseil socialiste guimolet pour la
conduite des opérations d'Algérie soit
les mieux placés aujourd'hui pour nous
donner des leçons d'histoire voire de
morale il ne peut pas il ne pas il ne
doit pas y avoir de mémoire sélective ou
de mémoire à sens unique à nous souvenir
nous devons nous souvenir de tout Oui
souvenons-nous que la guerre d'Algérie
ne s'est pas arrêté 19 mars ni même le 2
juillet 1962 souvenons-nous des soldats
du contingent tués ou blessés après
cette date soit quelques 225000 hommes
en armes à la veille du cesser le feu
là-bas 537 soldats sont tombés après le
19 mars souvenons-nous que les périodes
ouvrant droit au titre de reconnaissance
de la Nation ont été étendu jusqu'à la
date du 1er juillet 1964 pour l'Algérie
souvenons-nous que les accords déviants
n'ont d'accord que le nom car le car car
ils n'ont pu être respectés et en
particulier les garanties de sécurité
aux populations souvenons-nous que la
guerre d'Algérie ce sont aussi les
Français de souche européennes et les
Français de souche nord-africaines
conduit par navire à tout quitter à tout
perdre jusqu'à leur racine et à la tombe
et la tombe de leur mort souvendu des
100000 arquis et des 25000 pieds noirs
abandonnés par notre pays livré aux
tortures et au massacre du FLN après
après le 19 mars souvenons-nous
souvenons-nous de ces femmes de ces
enfants et de ces hommes tués dans une
fysiade le 26 mars 1962 à Alger ou bien
encore de ce massacré à Oran le 5
juillet 1962 un choix a été fait celui
du 5 décembre ce choix nous devons le
respecter sans chercher à sans chercher
à raviver les blessures du passé en
confondant devoir de mémoire et
surenchère électorale quel que soit le
poids de telle ou telle association
d'AFN dans nos départements si nous
voulons que notre débat a quelque
utilité alors servons-nous du passé pour
comprendre le présent et dessiner
l'avenir je crois qu'il faut avoir
seulement la fierté et la communion de
la nation dans le souvenir des français
morts au service du pays tel n'est pas
le cas de cette proposition de loi
lourde de calcul et de sous-entendu qui
montre bien que malheureusement nous
n'en avons pas fini avec vos vieux
démons c'est pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre c'est pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre dont je sais vos attachement
envers tous ceux qui ont sacrifié avec
courage les plus belles années de leur
jeunesse au service de la France et ceux
qui ont laissé leur vie je sollicite
votre sagesse pour demander dans un
souci de rassemblement national le
retrait de cette proposition de loi
cette sagesse dont cette sagesse dont
avait fait preuve votre prédécesseur
Monsieur Jean-Pierre masser mais aussi
son successeur monsieur mecera il y a 10
ans déjà à propos du 19 mars ce qui
avait conduit le Premier ministre
monsieur Jospin à ne pas demander
l'inscription de ce texte au Sénat il
n'y avait pas consciensus il y a 10 ans
il n'y a pas de consensus aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi je voterai contre cette
proposition de loi si elle est
mainten je
vouscie suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marc
toleskini pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
membres du groupe socialiste je voterai
le texte qui retient aujourd'hui notre
attention c'est pas grave
Gérard cette question du 19 mars je la
connais bien je rappellerai ici en effet
que je fus le chef de cabinet du
ministre qui donna un nom au conflit
d'Algérie ce ministre mon prédécesseur
l'a cité c'était Jean-Pierre Masseret
cette reconnaissance de l'état de guerre
a permis aux citoyens de notre pays de
se réapproprier une page d'histoire que
l'absence de nom avait
marginalisé mais ce ministère fut
également celui qui lança la création
d'un mémorial national pour les
combattants d'Algérie un nom un mémorial
deux actes construit avec l'unanimité
des parlementaires des associations et
pourquoi ne pas le dire avec l'unanimité
des
Français ce ministère ne donna pas de
date à la guerre d'Algérie manque de
courage pour en penser certains lucidité
répondrant d'autres alors de cette date
parlons-en la France présente un riche
calendrier de date commémorative pour
les guerres contemporaines trois pour la
Première Guerre mondiale le 2 novembre
voté des 1919 le 11 novembre voté en
1922 et la fête de Jeanne d'c n'oublions
pas en effet que cette dernière date fut
choisie au lendemain de la Première
Guerre mondiale pour remercier Jeanne
lalorine d'avoir participé au sauvetage
une deuxième fois de la
France quatre dates pour la seconde
guerre mondiale le dernier dimanche du
mois d'avril pour la déportation le 8
mai pour la capitulation des armées nazi
le 18 juin pour l'appel du général de
Gaulle et le dimanche le plus près du 16
juillet pour la rafle du veldive et déjà
trois dates pour les guerres de
décolonisation le 8 juin pour la
noochine le 25 septembre pour les archis
et le 5 décembre pour les les
combattants et les rapatriés
d'Algérie ce riche calendrier qui
traduit une exceptionnalité française
c'est'est encore enrichi en ce début
d'année 2012 d'une interprétation du 11
novembre pourquoi vous le cachez je suis
sensible à l'Union nationale qui a
toujours prévalu au moment des votes qui
portaiit création de ces journées
commémorative à l'exception du 18 juin
du 8 juin et du 5 décembre qui ont été
créés par décret toutes les autres dates
ont été voté à
l'unanimité cette unanimité permet à
tous les Français de partager une
mémoire commune cette union nationale
mémorielle pouvons-nous l'atteindre pour
la guerre d'Algérie Ernest Renand dans
célèbre discours sur la nation
définissait avec précision ce qui
constitue le socle de la nation
française un plébiscite de tous les
jours en clair l'envie de vivre ensemble
est une mémoire partagée et cette
mémoire Ernest Renand rappelé en 1885
les moments de deuil partagés unissent
plus que les moments de fête la guerre
de 1418 exceptionnelle et tragique
moment de deuil partagé par tous les
Français et l'exemple par excellence du
modèle de la mémoire
républicaine le 11 novembre est par
excellence la date du plus grand
rassemblement mémoriel et la guerre
d'Algérie est-elle un deuil partagé
est-elle un moment de rassemblement
mémoriel je n'étonnerai personne dans
cet hémicycle et encore en
écoutant le sénateur Carl en vous disant
que nous en sommes hélas encore très
loin pour les rapatriés nos compatriotes
cette guerre marque un formidable moment
de rupture avec une terre qui était la
leure pour les archis dont si peu ont
été accueillis sur notre territoire
elle marque le temps de l'abandon et
pour un grand nombre d'entre eux des
dizaines de milliers le temps des
massacres et des curies pour de nombreux
militaire enfin dont beaucoup avaient
combattu en Indochine la fin de la
guerre d'Algérie marque la fin d'une
histoire à laquelle ils avaient cru
celle du grande France qui ne voyait
jamais le soleil se coucher une date
commémorative est une sorte de carillon
dans la sonnerie chaque année réveille
les souvenirs mais faut-il encore que
ces souvenirs soient partagés par tous
ceux qui entendent raisonner r le 19
mars est un moment partagé par un grand
nombre de combattants du contingent ces
hommes qui jeûent alors ont répondu aux
ordres donnés par les gouvernements
successifs pour combattre en Algérie
tous ils ont su à ce moment-là placer
leur destin individuel non celui de la
nation je respecte leur désir de voir le
19 mars être leur DAC carillné à leurs
yeux cette date achèvera leur
reconnaissance comme génération du feu
11 novembre 8 mai 19 mars mars je
respecte le combat d'une grande
fédération d'anciens combattants qui
depuis 1963 tente de faire partager au
plus grand nombre sans désir
calendaire je comprends la force du
souvenir de ces centaines de milliers
d'appelés qui l'oreille collé au
transistor crier leur joie le 18 mars
1962 lors de la signature des accords
déviant je comprends mais je ne peux
m'empêcher de penser à tous les
Européens d'Algérie et à tous les
Algériens qui l'oreille collé au même
transistor pleurer et s'interroger sur
les drames à venir j'espère oui j'espère
que cette date du 19 mars sera capable
d'unifier ce qui riaent et ceux qui
pleuraient en écoutant les mêmes
actualités j'ai foi dans cette espérance
mais vous l'avez bien compris je n'ai
plus m'empêcher d'exprimer aussi mon
inquiétude je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieurini
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame isson pour le
groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre dans
votre propos liminaire vous nous avez
déclaré que le Sénat et la chambre de la
réflexion
de la mesure et de la sagesse on se PL à
le rappeler et qu'il convient pour
construire un avenir commun de regarder
notre passé en Phe dans le respect de
toutes les victimes le 19 mars 1962 et
la proclamation du cesselfeu en Algérie
suite aux accords d'éviant signé la
veille ce n'est pas la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie reconnue comme telle depuis
octobre
1999 nous avons été unanimes à
l'exprimer lors des échanges de qualité
que nous avons partagé en commission des
affaires sociales des appelés les
rapatriés les archis ont été de
terribles victimes après le 19 mars mais
notre rapporteur l'a rappelé avec
beaucoup de gravité et je veux le citer
il est temps d'apporter une réponse à
ceux qui entre 1954 et
1962 ont répondu à l'appel de la nation
avec abnégation et courage dans le
respect des lois de la République et
quelqu que soit la vie individuelle
qu'il portait sur la gerre
d'Algérie le 5 décembre 2003
l'inauguration du Mémorial national de
la guerre d'Algérie des combats du Maroc
et de la Tunisie par le Président de la
République Jacques Chirac c'est une
belle reconnaissance des terribles
événements vécus alors c'est tout cela
ce n'est que cela le 16 octobre
1977 d' d'inumation du soldat inconnu à
Notre-Dame de Laurette c'est c'est la
réunion des anciens combattants en grand
nombre et vous avez pu le constater
monsieur le ministre mais ce n'est pas
une date
historique
parlementaire nous devons prendre acte
des dates de l'histoire et comme
beaucoup d'entre nous je le pense nous
n'avons pas à commenter l'histoire voter
cette proposition de loi c'est proposer
les voix de la réconciliation et de la
paix aucun des destins individuels fait
d'épreuves et de douleur ne peut être
lié mais au-delà d'eux s'impose le
destin de notre communauté nationale
prenons aujourd'hui le temps du
recueillement du souvenir écoutons
respectons ceux qui acteurs des heures
sans doute les plus déchirante de notre
histoire nationale ont un besoin
d'apaisement de réconciliation
oui songons aux trop nombreux jeunes
gens du contingent venus de tous nos
territoires qui au début de la
construction de leur vie envie
brutalement s'arrêter l'élan de leur
futur oui songeons au arquis odieusement
abandonné pour beaucoup d'entre eux
après le 19 mars oui n'oublions pas les
rapatriés obligés d'abandonner une terre
qui était la leure en commission notre
collègue madame bruger l'a rappelé avec
gravité et émotion mais le 19 mars est
une date que l'histoire imposera quand
ensemble nous partageons les mêmes
douleurs aucune comparaison n'est valide
quand on parle de guerre
mais au nom de la mémoire républicaine
comme vient de l'indiquer notre collègue
todchini je veis néanmoins évoquer nos
destins partagés quand dans le Pas de
calis en 2014 nous nous recueillerons
ennemi d'hier amis aujourd'hui sur le
site de notred-dame de Laurette devant
ta m mororial reconnaissant dans une
fraternité Postume 600000 morts des
batailles de la Première Guerre mondiale
des batailles d'Artois venu du monde
monde entier mes chers collègues dans le
respect de toutes les victimes sachons
conscients de nos
responsabilités choisir une date
historique en faisant appel à l'union
nationale à la
réconciliation je vous remercie madame
Génisson la discussion générale est
close qui veulent répondre bon bien nous
passons à la discussion de la motion
tendant à opposer l'exception
d'recevabilité monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous souhaitez
intervenir
oui monsieur le Président
merci simplement pour dire très
sereinement à nos collègues que ce débat
a été d'une grande tenue en
commission je souhaite qu'il continue à
se dérouler dans le même climat
de
réflexion pour ma part j'ai écouté et
j'ai
entendu avec émotion les paroles des uns
et des autres exprimant des douleurs des
douleurs certes différentes mais des
douleurs partagées par l'ensemble de la
nation et je crois que aujourd'hui à
travers le texte que nous discutons il
convient de faire
ensemble que le 19 mars devienne
effectivement un jour de recueillement
et de souvenir de mémoire pour toutes
les victimes de la guerre
d'Algérie toutes les victimes qui ont
uvré dans le sens du respect des lois de
la
République mes chers collègues je crois
que à travers notre discussion et à
travers notre vote nous ferons en
sorte que aucune douleur ne soit oublié
aucune douleur ne soit ignorée il n'y a
pas de hiérarchisation dans les douleurs
les peines et les deuils il faut que la
France rassemblée rende hommage à tous
ceux effectivement qui ont été victimes
de la guerre d'Algérie de cette guerre
cruelle qui trop longtemps n'a pas osé
dire son nom et qui doit aujourd'hui
trouver enfin une date mais une date
historique et symbolique pour que la 3è
génération du feu soit traitée à égalité
avec ces deux dev vancièr
merci
madame Joë garot Mélan et les membres du
groupe Union pour un mouvement populaire
ont déposé une motion distribuée sous le
numéro 4 tendant à opposer l'exception
du recevabilité au texte en discussion
la parole est à Madame Joë garot Mélan
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues trois
interrogations m'amèent ce matin à
considérer avec mes collègues du groupe
UMP que ce texte n'est pas
constitutionnel et qu'il est en fait
contraire au principes édictés par la
constitution de notre pays tout d'abord
alors que la France traverse une très
grave crise et que le calendrier
législative ne semble pas moins chargé
que d'habitude mes chers collègues je
m'interroge sur la pertin de voter une
proposition de loi dont les dispositions
sont déjà satisfaites par le dispositif
législatif en
vigueur l'article 1er de ce texte tend à
instituer une journée d'hommage à la
mémoire des victimes civiles et
militaires de la guerre d'Algérie et des
combats en Tunisie et au Maroc or
celle-ci cette journée d'hommage existe
depuis
2003 le décr du 26 septembre 2003 a en
effet institué je
cite si vous pouviez écouter le texte du
décret une
journée j'espère prés que les temps
d'interruption seront déduit du temps
qui est imparti à la présentation de
cette motion
d'irrecevabilité le décret du 26
septembre 2003 je répète et je en effet
institué une journée nationale d'hommage
aux morts pour la France pendant la
guerre d'Algérie et les combat du Maroc
et de la Tunisie fin de citation ces
dispositions ont été complétées 2 ans
plus tard par la loi du 23 février 2005
portant je cite reconnaissance de la
Nation et la contribution nationale en
faveur des Français rapatriés fin de
citation cette loi rend solennellement
au age aux personnes disparues et aux
populations civiles victime de massacre
ou d'exaction commis durant la guerre
d'Algérie et après le 19 mars
1962 en violation des accords des viants
ainsi que victime civiles des combats de
Tunisie et du Maroc elle reconnaît ainsi
les souffrances éprouvées et les
sacrifices endurés par les rapatriés les
anciens membres des formations
supplétives et assimilé les dis paru et
les victimes civiles et militaires des
événements liés au processus
d'indépendance de ces anciens
départements et territoires l'objet de
l'article 1er de la présente proposition
de loi est donc d'ors et déjà satisfait
quant au second et dernier article du
texte dont nous débattons ce matin il
propose que la date de cette
commémoration soit fixée au 19 mars si
la journée dommage nationale est
actuellement clébré le 5 décembre rien
n'empêche les associations qui le
souhaitent d'organiser par ailleurs des
cérémonies le 19 mars et d'y associer si
nécessaire des représentants de l'État
nul besoin d'une nouvelle loi pour cela
j'estime donc que les dispositions de
cette proposition de loi sont déjà
satisfaites par le cadre légal actuel et
que ce texte encombre donc
inutilement un calendrier Parlement
déjà bien trop
chargé ma seconde objection à l'examen
de ce texte concerne le respect de la
procédure de navette parlementaire telle
que décrite à l'article 45 de notre
Constitution qu'est-ce qui justifie
constitutionnellement l'immortalité
d'une petite loi il me semblerait utile
que le Conseil constitutionnel se
prononce sur la validité d'un vote par
le Sénat d'une proposition de loi
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale plus
de 10 ans auparavant nous exhumons
aujourd'hui une petite loi votée par
l'Assemblée le 22 janvier 2002 il y a
plus de 10 ans sans
vouloir sans sans vouloir retracer
l'histoire parlementaire et
institutionnelle de la 5e République
trois élections présidentielles ont eu
lieu depuis auxquelles sont ajouté trois
élections législatives ainsi qu'un
renouvellement total du Sénat la
représentation nationale n'est donc plus
du tout la même qu'il y a 10 ans ce qui
soulève de lourdes incertitudes quant à
la valeur juridique de ce
texte se pose à nous la question de la
pérennité ou de la caducité des textes
déposés sur le bureau d'une des deux
assemblées parlementaires et ce point de
vue dépend dans quelle chambre nous nous
nous trouvons la coutume veut qu'à
chaque renouvellement de l'Assemblée
nationale les textes transmis par le
Sénat lors de la précédente législature
soit frappé de caducité l'inverse n'est
pas vrai certains me répondront que
c'est parce que le Sénat est une chambre
pérenne cet argument serait défendable
si le délai entre le passage à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat était restreint
mais depuis 10 ans je le répète le Sénat
a été renouvelé totalement un autre
argument justifiant l'immortalité d'une
loi et le fait que le vote des
parlementaires traduise une volonté
générale placée hors du temps
l'expression de la volonté générale
prime évidemment sur toute technique
procédurale mais dans le cas qui nous
occupe le texte que nous discutons
aujourd'hui n'est que la petite loi
votée par l'Assemblée nationale en 2002
elle n donc en rien le statut
d'expression de la volonté
générale comble des paradoxes notre
rapporteur sénateur depuis septembre
2011 a été préalablement député entre
1988 et
1993 puis s discontinuer depuis
1997 jusqu'à son arrivée dans notre
Haute Assemblée mais non je vous en
félicite vous l'aurez compris en 2002
lors du vote par l'Assemblée nationale
du texte qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui à la nerie était législateur
donc auteur du texte comment peut-on
démocratiquement expliquer qu'une loi
puisse être votée dans une chambre et
dans une autre par les mêmes
parlementaires ce délai de 10
ans ce délai de 10 ans entre le vote à
l'Assemblée nationale et l'examen du
texte au Sénat est d'autant plus
contestable sur le plan constitutionnel
qu'entrreetemp une autre loi a été votée
par le Parlement celle du 23 février
2005 portant reconnaissance de la Nation
et la contribution nationale en faveur
des Français rapatriés une petite loi
votée uniquement par une seule des deux
chambres il y a une décennie permettrait
de justifier la remise en cause d'une
loi plus récente votée elle par
l'ensemble des
parlementaires le texte dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui qui prétend
instituer une journée demage alors
qu'elle existe déjà et donc mensonger il
eut été intellectuellement plus honnête
et juridiquement plus rigoureux de
déposer une proposition de loi
visant à décaler du 5 décembre au 19
mars la date de la
commémoration rien nempêche les
socialistes de détricoter la loi de 2005
mais une éthique parlementaire minimale
voudrait qu'il suiv pour cela la
procédure parlementaire normale telle
que décrite à l'article 45 de notre
Constitution cela supposerait de rédiger
une nouvelle
de loi tenant compte du dispositif
législatif en vigueur et notamment de la
loi de 2005 et de la faire voter par les
deux
chambres une telle démarche aurait
d'ailleurs parfaitement pu être adoptée
puisquealin lui-même avait déposé une
proposition de loi en ce sens le 5
janvier dernier pourquoi ne pas l'avir
inscrite à l'ordre du jour du Sénat la
place de cette petite loi de 10 ans d'â
au statut juridique douteux
pourquoi même avoir cherché à cacher
cette proposition de loin en nomant de
la joindre à la
discussion tous ces indices nous
montrent que le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale sont bien
conscients du caractère
constitutionnellement douteux de leur
manœuvre conscient que leur proposition
divise profondément la nation il refuse
de prendre le risque de son examen par
l'Assemblée nationale espérant réussir à
forcer la main au
Sénat c'est d'ailleurs cette même
logique de passage en force qui a
conduit le gouvernement à avancer
l'examen du texte du 20 au 8
novembre monsieur le
ministre il y a de semaines ici même
vous nous avez déclaré vous en remettre
à la sagesse du Sénat dans le plein
respect des prérogatives du Parlement
car c'est à ce dernier je vous cite
qu'il incombe d'achever un processus
législatif qu'il a lui-même engagé et ce
sans aucune ingérence ni interférence de
la part de
l'exécutif c'était un acte courageux et
digne que je tiens à saluer monsieur le
ministre mais quelques jours plus tard
le gouvernement vous a contredit en
faisant inscrire en catimini cette
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour sur
le créneau qui lui est réservé au lieu
de conserver un examen au 20 novembre
comme initialement
prévu quelle raison impérieuse a pu
pousser à une telle modification
s'agissait-il simplement de prendre de
cours les nombreuses associations du
monde combattant qui préparaient une
mobilisation de grande envergure pour le
20 novembre peut-être mais au-delà de
cela cette précipitation me semble avoir
un un lien avec l'agenda diplomatique du
président de la
République ceci m'amène à ma troisème
objection cette proposition de loi ne
porte pas sur des matière appartenant au
domaine de la loi tel que définie à
l'article 34 de la
Constitution je dénonce donc une
instrumentalisation de la loi à des fins
de politique politicien
et de gouvernance diplomatique je
m'explique quel est l'objet de ah oui ça
vous gênerait bien sûr quel est l'objet
de ce texte la réponse paraît simple
commémorer la mémoire des victimes
civiles et militaires de la gerre
d'Algérie et des combats en Tunisie au
Maroc ce qui s'opposeraiit à un projet
de mémoire si légitime ne serait donc
que d'affreux révisionnistes niant les
drames engendrés par cette guerre gu de
décolonisation sauf que comme je vous
l'ai indiqué précédemment une telle
journée demage existe déjà depuis 2003
et rien n'empêche actuellement les
associations de commémorer le 19 mars
sans que cela ne soit clairement indiqué
dans le texte la polémique ne porte pas
sur cette journée de commémoration mais
bien à travers elle sur une possible
réinterprétation officiel par la France
de la portée des accords déviants c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui avait poussé François
Béran à déclarer je cite si une date
doit être officialisée pour célébrer le
souvenir de la guerre d'Algérie cela ne
peut-être le 19 mars qu'il y aura
confusion dans la mémoire de notre
peuple citation de Monsieur François
miteron cette proposition de loi tente
via l'instrumentalisation d'une journée
mémori
de réécrire l'histoire car elle vise à
raviver l'éclivage en tentant d'imposer
une relecture simpliste de l'histoire
franco-algérienne dont la repentance
française serait le seul axiome et en
faisant passer pour des révisionnistes
post-coloniaux les tenant d'une approche
moins
idéologique la guerre d'Algérie est une
page tragique de notre histoire dont il
est important de garder la mémoire mais
les commémorations ne doivent pas être
utilisées pour diviser et pour raviver
les blessur elles doivent être au
contraire l'occasion de regarder
l'histoire dans toute sa
complexité algérien et français ont une
longue histoire commune faite de
souffrance mais aussi de belles
réalisation enfin je voudrais souligner
le contexte international dans lequel
intervient ce débat le président de la
République se rendra le mois prochain en
Algérie et il semble donc que c'est pour
pouvoir faire un usage politicien et
diplomatique de ce texte qui l'enbrusque
l'examen au mépris de l'esprit du
processus de navette parlementaire
d'autant que notre débat intervient
alors même que le ministre algérien des
anciens combattants annonce que les
Algériens veulent je cite une
reconnaissance franche des crimes
perpétrés à leur encontre par le
colonialisme français n'est-il pas
dangereux mes chers collègues
d'instrumentaliser ainsi l'histoire et
la mémoire quels impératifs justifient
aujourd'hui un tel mépris pour la
procédure parlementaire un tel dénis de
démocratie si ce texte périmé est voté
au terme d'une procédure
mon vicier nous saisirons le Conseil
constitutionnel et c'est lui qui en
appréciera lui-même la
validité je vous
remercie madame Joë garot Mélan la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Didier
Guillaume contre la
motion
Mons
le monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues
j'interviens effectivement suite à cette
motion et comme l'a très bien dit notre
rapporteur et l'esprit dans lequel le
ministre est intervenu lors de la
première séance ce genre de discussions
ne doivent pas ne doivent pas être des
discussions de
division il y a des positions qui sont
prises par les uns et par les
autres moi je respecte la position des
uns et des autres et ça c'est normal
mais admettez quand même mes chers
collègues que la majorité de cette
assemblée puisse avoir une position
différente puisse l'exprimer et c'est
quand même surprenant de s'adresser au
au Conseil constitutionnel pour mener un
combat politique parce que lorsque
j'entends lorsque j'entend sur un sujet
comme
celui-ci mensonge
honnêteté éthique passage en force
petites lois caractère douteux de la
manœuvre je pense
que à des jeunes à l'époque étaient
partis de chez eux puis pour une
opération de maintien de l'ordre et
lorsque plusieurs milliers ne sont pas
revenus lorsque certains ont été blessés
toute leur vie dans leur corps ou dans
leur tête lorsque nous voulons rendre
hommage à tous ces gens-là alors ce
n'est pas des mensonges d'éthique ou
d'honnêteté dont il s'agit c'est tout
simplement de réconciliation nationale
et du devoir de mémoire dont nous devons
tous porter tous les jours
cela et loin comme ça vient d'être dit
par la précédente oratrice de diviser et
de raviver les blessures nous voulons
rassembler et fermer ces blessures et il
n'y a pas de petite loi et j'ai été
assez choqué je je ne suis qu'un jeune
parlementaire mais il n'y a pas de
petites loi il y a les lois de la
démocratie politique française qu'elle
soit votée à l'Assemblée ou au Sénat une
loi en une autre et quand les
représentants du peuple la votent
majoritairement de façon démocratique
alors cette loi en vaut une autre et je
n'accepte pas le fait que l'on dise
qu'il y a des petites lois c'est la
raison pour laquelle cont tenu du fait
que au Sénat les lois ne sont pas
purgées nous rejetons cette motion
d'irrecevabilité et j'ai bien entendu ce
que disait madame que si cette loi était
votée il y aurait un recours au Conseil
constitutionnel il y en a beaucoup le
conseil fera ce qu'il a à faire mais
franchement mes chers collègues comment
évoquer cette proposition de loi et ce
débat sur
l'irrecevabilités sans d'abord en
ressentir le poids de l'histoire et vous
l'avez fait les uns et les autres je
pense avec autant d'honnêteté à cette
tribune ceux qui étaient pour cette loi
et ceux qui étaient contre et il peut y
avoir des visions totalement différentes
parce que cette guerre d'Algérie est une
guerre qui aura marqué une part de notre
mémoire colctive nous l'avons tous vécu
cette guerre d'Algérie de près ou de
loin nous en avons entendu parler à la
maison ou plutôt ou plusut tôt nous en
avons assez peu entendu parler parce
qu'à l'époque ceux qui sont revenus ne
voulaient pas en parler certains l'ont
fait j'en ai eu dans ma famille j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour tous ces petits
gars comme disait le Général Bijard qui
sont partis là-bas il y en a trop qui ne
sont pas revenu et à partir de là cette
guerre d'Algérie elle a quand même
contribué à diviser les familles tout au
long de ces années de ceux qui avaient
vécu de ceux qui en parlaient et de ceux
qui qui en sont revenus je veux avoir
une pensée pour ces familles pour tous
ces jeunes et pour tous leurs enfants
tous ceux qui sont allés là-bas ont été
meurtris dans leur corps dans leur tête
garde des séquelles à jamais au fond au
fond d'eux- même à jamais ont été gravés
en eux ces atrocités et nous devons
honorer les morts les blessés tous les
morts tous les blessés les morts au
combat les morts dans les attentats ce
ce qui ont été torturés il n'y a pas de
niveau de qualité entre les morts et les
blessés tous qu'ils étent été militaires
français archis algérien Français
d'Algérie nous devons tous avoir une
pensée ensemble c'est ça le
rassemblement républicain qui doit être
marqué
ici une guerre qui ne voulait pas dire
son nom j'en ai dit un mot à l'instant
lorsque en
1999 le gouvernement a fait voter à a
indiqué clairement que c'était une
guerre d'Algérie et non pas une une
opération du maintien de l'ordre ou non
pas les événements d'Algérie comme ça a
été fait ça a été un acte fort
symbolique important pour notre nation
un acte de rassembl de rassemblement de
la nation oui tous ces jeunes qui
étaient partis en Algérie par le bateau
ils sont allés pour faire la guerre
cette guerre a été reconnue en
1999 et nous avons tous pensé que
c'était une bonne chose qu'il y ait eu
cette reconnaissance par le gouvernement
de Jospin et tout à l'heure notre
collègue le Kester todeskini évoquait le
ministre Jean-Pierre masseré cette
adoption par le Parlement a été quelque
chose de très important et puis il y a
eu il y a 50 ans les accords des Viant
ils ont été signé et pourtant nombre
d'entre nous on ont continue à entendu
ont continué à entendre parler de cette
guerre et de ses conséquences les
référendums relatifs à la guerre
d'Algérie le général de Gaulle les
utilisé à deux reprises vous citiez tout
à l'heure madame François mitteron je
pourrais citer le général de Gaulle le
général de Gaulle était un visionnaire
il a vu ce qui s'est passé après cette
guerre d'Algérie et lorsque le 8 janvier
1961 le général de Gaulle propose un
référendum sur l'autodétermination en
Algérie quelle est la question je lis je
cite Approuvez-vous le projet de loi
soumis au peuple français par le
Président de la République concernant
l'autodétermination des population
algérienne et l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics en Algérie avant
l'autodétermination et le oui l'emporte
à 75 % des suffrages exprimés plus de 17
millions de voix le général de Gaulle le
8 avril
62 le 8 avril 62 le général de Gaulle
propose un deuxème référendum sur les
accords des viillons Approuvez-vous le
projet de loi soumis au peuple français
concernant les accords établis les
mesures à prendre au sujet de l'Algérie
sur la base des déclarations
gouvernementales du 19 mars 62 que le
général de Gaulle avait reconnu là
encore il s'agissait d'approuver les
accords des Viant et le CER le feu du 19
mars le oui l'emporte avec 90 % des
suffrages exprimés mais évidemment tout
ne s'est pas arrêté le 20 mars au matin
vous l'avez tous dit et nous le
reconnaissons toutes et toutes il y a eu
des drames humains et l'histoire de
France en est encore marquée tout à
l'heure a été évoquée la visite du
président de de la République France
Hollande en
Algérie les relations franco-algériennes
sont parfois tumultueuses elles l'ont
été par le passé et l'ensemble des
présidents de la République qui sont
succédés ont rencontré les présidents
algériens s'y sont rendus et je salue là
notre collègue Claude domzel qui est le
président du groupe interparlementaire
d'amitié France francealgérie oui il y a
besoin que de par et d'autres de la
Méditerranée les relations politiques
citoyennes soient les plus fortes
possibles et la visite du président de
la public servira à renforcer cela et ce
n'est pas cette loi qui rajoutera quoi
que ce so quoi que ce soit mais cette
relation là elle est indispensable des
deux côtés de la Méditerranée des femmes
et des hommes ont souffert il faut
aujourd'hui regarder vers l'avenir aller
de l'avant et écrire le futur
appréhendant justement le passé alors je
voudrais maintenant saluer notre
rapporteur monsieur
alenerie qui dans ses convictions tout
au long de ces années
à l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
parce qu'enfin il n'est pas impensable
d'être à la fois d'être après avoir été
député sénateur il y en a quelques-uns
ici il y en a quelques-uns où est où est
le problème politique c'est la
démocratie ce sont les les les les
électeurs et bien cette journée du 19
mars qui devra devenir la Journée
nationale du souvenir et de
recueillement à la mémoire des victimes
civiles et militaires de la guerre
d'Algérie et des combats en Tunisie et
au Maroc elle est indispensable que l'on
s'entende bien cette reconnaissance ne
vise pas à décréter ou à imposer une
date qui marquerait la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie le 19 mars 62 c'est d'abord et
avant tout le lendemain du 18 mars et de
la signature des accords déviant le 19
mars c'est la date du CESS le feu mais
les combats nous l'avons dit le
rapporteur l'a dit ne se sont pas
arrêtés le 19 mars ils ont continué mais
le rapporteur l'a très bien dit aussi
après euh le le le 18 novembre le après
le 11 novembre 1918 il y a eu les
combats d'Orient après le 8 mai 45 il y
a eu d'autres combats et nous pouvons le
déplorer il ne s'agit pas ici de
commémorer la fin de la guerre d'Algérie
il s'agit tout simplement qu'il y ait
une date afin de célébrer d'honorer
toutes les victimes de la guerre
d'Algérie toutes sans aucune exception
quelles é été leur histoire quelles é
été tout cela et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne souhaitons pas opposer
les dates les unes aux autres nous ne
souhaitons pas les opposer nous disons
simplement que le 19 mars est la date
qui nous semble correspondre à un fait à
une histoire et que nous souhaitons que
cette date soit officialisé comme celle
du cesser le feu de la guerre en Algérie
voilà ce que nous demandons et je ne
vois pas ce qu'il y a
d'anticonstitutionnel là-dedans et je ne
vois pas ce qu'il y a qui diviserait la
nation bien au contraire c'est une date
de rassemblement je le disais tout à
l'heure parce que mes chers collègues le
19 mars devant les monuments aux morts
et nous pouvons le le regretter parce
que l'âge des anciens combattants de la
Première Guerre mondiale il n'y en a
plus et de la 2uxè Guerre mondiale ils
sont de plus en plus âgés et de moins en
moins nombreux qui a-t-il dans les
monuments aux morts devant les monuments
aux morts le 8 mai le 11 novembre et
bien sûr le 19 mars il y a les
combattants de l'Algérie c'est cela la
réalité et dans quelques années ce
seront les derniers envis pour
transmettre la flamme transmettre la
mémoire transmettre notre histoire le
devoir de mémoire il est indispensable
on sait très bien aujourd'hui que ceux
qui ont fait la guerre d'Algérie sont
les plus nombreux pour transmettre cette
mémoire et pour contribuer à avancer
dans ce devoir de de de mémoire mais
nous sommes nombreux dans toutes les
villes de France le 19 mars il a il y a
des drapeaux dans mon département sur
300 69 communes 304 ont une place un
monument une rue du 19 mars en France
c'est plus de 4000 artères plus de 800
sites personnalisés plus de 1500 lieux à
la mémoire du 19 mars alors cette PPL à
notre sens elle n'a rien
d'anticonstitutionnel bien au contraire
elle nous permet d'entreprendre une
démarche de reconnaissance le 19 mars ce
n'est ni la victoire des uns ni la
défaite des autres je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure et nous voulons honorer tout le
monde saluer les archis qui ont été
abandonnés par la France saluer les les
rapatriés d'Algérie qui étaient nés sur
le sol d'Algérie pour qu'il y avait tout
leurs investissements leur famille leur
histoire et qui ont dû partir après
saluer les familles saluer les soldats
saluer ceux qui ont été victimes
d'attentat terroristes toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont souffert pendant les
la guerre d'Algérie aujourd'hui ils sont
reconnus et nous voulons vraiment leur
rendre leur rendre hommage ce n'est donc
ni la victoire des uns ni la défaite des
autres il ne s'agit pas d'évoquer une
défaite militaire il s'agit de se
souvenir de toutes les victimes
d'Algérie sans aucune exception le 19
mars si cette loi est adoptée sera la
date officielle du recueillement et du
souvenir la date du rassemblement et du
devoir de mémoire la date de notre
histoire et de notre mémoire commune je
vous
remercie je vous
remercie è monsieur
Guillaume je vais demander par
conséquent l'avis de la
commission la la Commission donne un
avis
défavorable quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur Cader Harif
ministre chargé des anciens
combattants pas prévu forcément
d'intervenir et puis je ne reste inscrit
dans ce qu' a été mon propos ni
interférence ni ingérence dans ce qui
est le travail parlementaire et donc
respectueux de la sagesse de ce travail
parlementaire et des choix qui seront
opérés néanmoins néanmoins corriger au
moins de choses travers du débat que
j'ai pu
entendre la première des choses c'est
difficile et mon histoire personnelle
aurait pu me conduire à avoir des
expressions nourres par beaucoup
d'émotions et c'est des choses que
j'évite non seulement dans la
responsabilité qui est la mienne mais
au-delà de la responsabilité dans mon
rapport à ma propre
citoyenneté de la même manière je
voudrais corriger deux choses le
président de la République oui se
déplacera en Algérie je ne reviendrai
pas sur ce déplacement mais il y a au
moins une chose sur lequel il ne peut
pas y avoir procès c'est que le
Président de la République j'ai eu
l'occasion d'accompagner dans d'autres
responsabilités en Algérie a toujours
été ferme sur l'idée que la France
n'était pas dans la repentance et
c'était quelque chose qu'il fallait que
je renouvelle ici devant
vous la deuxème chose à exprimer sur le
choix je peux entendre cette question
pourquoi le gouvernement a permis
de faire ou d'offrir la possibilité
qu'on puisse rediscuter ou finir ce
débat sur Mars aujourd'hui j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure des
choses je sais pas si je suis jeune ou
vieux politique mais quand même avec un
peu d'expérience qui sont parfois un peu
difficile à entendre sur l'idée qu'il y
aurait une utilisation du
gouvernement à travers l'étude de cette
loi ou de cette proposition de de loi
euh d'essayer de trouver une majorité
pour je ne sais quel texte au Sénat et
cetera si tel était le cas je me
déplacerai pas avec monsieur le ministre
de la Défense le 20 novembre à Fréjus
pour les cendres du général
Bijard donc c'était le 20 novembre me
semble-t-il qui avait été prévu comme
niche et donc voilà c'est dans ce souci
d'apaisement et de regard sur l'ensemble
de l'histoire quel que soit les
difficulté qui se pose qu'il y a eu
cette proposition qui a été faite donc
sagesse pour moi en tout cas et respect
du vote du Parlement du
S y a-t-il des explications de vote
monsieur
raquier monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues j'avais
15 ans en
1962 et je me souviens très bien de la
Gard d'Algérie et de l'inquiétude dans
la population car chacun avait un mari
un frère ou un fils sur la terre
d'Afrique et je me souviens quand enfant
des écoles nous sommes allés trois fois
au cimetière dans ma commune Martel dans
le Lot 1500 habitants trois fois au
cimetière pour enterrer des victimes
l'Algérie cétait un gendarme Un militat
d'active et un sal du contingent et il y
avait un piquet d'honneur il ne passait
pas aux Invalides à ce moment-là et on
enterrait disons tout à fait
discrètement il faut bien le dire ces
gens qui revenaient d'Algérie alors donc
cet g d'Algérie mitait bien son nom donc
car c'est vrai qu'on parlait au début
d'opération de police de maintien de
l'ordre des forces armées dans les JB
d'événement d'Algérie la guerre est
reconnue maintenant il faudrait donc
clôturer tout ceci en reconnaissant la
date 19 mars c'est c'est le feu c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'exaction
après il y a eu donc les rapatriés qui
on été donc touchés dans leur chair il y
a eu les arquis penser au poivyè qui
sont qu'on a qui ont pu s'en sortir et
qu'on a en particulier dans l'Avon mis
au camp du Larzac gelé de froid au camp
du Larzac pensez donc au militaire au
militaire du contingent etactive
continuer à tomber pensez aux Européens
car c'est vrai que l'histoire il faut
rien cacher le 5 juillet à Aang 700
européens ont disparu donc tout ça c'est
la la suite mais je pense que cette
guerre d'Algérie mérite bien d'une date
qui donc nous commémorons déjà nous non
pas officiellement parce qu'on n' pas
droit au gendarmes ni même au
sous-préfet mais on le fait quand même
depuis longtemps c'est donc le 19 mars
alors je voudrais à terminer pour
remercier le rapporteur Alen nerry qui
au fil du temps après le l'assemblée
c'est vrai et au Sénat c lui qui a
défendu cette proposition de loi c'est
quelqu'un du de l'Auvergne c'est un rock
de granit et quand il a une idée il va
jusqu'au bout il a mis il 10 ans
j'espère que le vote sera favorable et
qu'on pourra revenir dans nos
départements en ayant le sentiment
d'avoir fait notre devoir donc en tout
cas cette motion nous allons pas le
groupe RDSE la 5e majorité ne la votera
pas les radicau de gauche voteront pas à
l'unanimité car nous estimons qu'elle
mérite discussion et approbationè
bien bien je vous remercie monsieur
réquier pour cette explication de vote
du groupe RDSE la parole est maintenant
pour explication de vote du groupe udi
UC à Monsieur Marseille
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre notre groupe votera la motion
votera la motion parce qu'à l'évidence
ce débat a montré une chose c'est qu'il
c'est une date qui divise c'est une date
qui divise les dates commémoratives
chaque fois qu'elles ont été approuvées
l'ont été dans le consensus
aujourd'hui le débat a témoigné d'une
chose c'est que les blessures liées à
l'Algérie sont encore des PL vive
extrêmement vive et qui affecte beaucoup
de familles dans notre pays et
l'évocation du 19 mars est une évocation
qui divise et qui blesse c'est vrai que
il y a eu les accords d'Oran c'est vrai
que il y a eu beaucoup d'espoir pour les
uns mais c'est vrai aussi que il y a eu
beaucoup d'événements chacun l'a redit
ici la rue d'isli les événements d'Oran
en juillet il y a encore beaucoup de
débats et à l'évidence il eû été sage de
ne pas rajouter une division
supplémentaire il fallait laisser
davantage de temps il fallait laisser
aux historiens le temps de travailler et
on a le sentiment euh que il y a une
volonté d'imposer cette date et euh de
de raviver les cl qui sont encore très
brûlantes c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur nous
voterons cette
motion je vous remercie monsieur
Marseille la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Louis negre pour le groupe
UMP bien monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président Madame
chers collègues nous débattons
aujourd'hui d'un
texte qui fait que nous avons une
manifestation à l'heure actuelle à
l'extérieur du
palais c'est donc mesdames messieurs et
chers collègues c'est donc un texte qui
contrairement à ce qu'a expliqué très
tranquillement monsieur le rapporteur
est un texte clivant c'est un texte qui
divise alors je ne reviendrai pas sur
les propos particulièrement argumentés
et charpentés de notre collègue garioot
M
sur les principes de cette loi qui sont
constraires à la
Constitution mais au-delà je
m'interroge sur l'opportunité de ce
texte par les temps qui
court pourquoi pourquoi alors qu'il
existe alors qu'il existe chers
collègues de très nombreux textes dont
la loi du 23 février 2005 pourquoi alors
que l'on peut célébrer d'ors et déjà 19
mars pourquoi pourquoi chers
collègues pourquoi avez-vous honte
pourquoi cette repentance continuelle et
perpétuelle pourquoi la France a fait un
certain nombre de choses qui était
effectivement hors norme ok d'accord et
les autres et les autres bon alors alors
alors à partir du moment à partir du
moment à partir du moment où vou
célébrer une commémoration qui ne divise
pas oui mais oui à une histoire
équilibrée oui à ce qu'on ouvre tous nos
livres d'histoire oui à ce qu'il y ait
une commission d'historiens
franco-algériens et neutre qui se
penchent dessus et qui disent ce qui
s'est réellement passé alors pourquoi
aujourd'hui cette loi donc on peut se
poser la question et on se l' poser pour
des raisons
politico-dplomatiques
vous le dites non mais d'autres pensent
l'inverse et si et si on peut comprendre
totalement qu'il faille s'entendre avec
l'Algérie oui parce qu'on s'est entendu
avec tous les pays dans lequel on était
en guerre et l'Allemagne est un très bon
exemple qui montre qu'on a pu s'entendre
avec l'Allemagne alors qu'elle avait eu
trois guerres il se trouve que cette
guerre là cette guerre d'Algérie a
frappé les gens et tout à l'heure un
d'entre nous ici disait mais 1418 il y a
eu des morts après bien sûr qu'il y a eu
des morts après
1418 mais ça s'est pas passé de cette
manière-là nous n'avons pas eu 1 million
de
rapatriés nous avons eu 145 morts 422
blessés 300 disparus et 50 50000 à
100000 150000 archis qui sont morts
après et tous les Français dans Algérie
qui sont rentrés tous ces Français là
aujourd'hui chers collègues quand quand
vous allez dans les associations de
rapatrier il y a des gens et qui
pleurent et qui continuent à pleurer ça
n'a rien à voir avec 141 alors pas de
repentance s'il vous plaît et je
remercie d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre
d'avoir dit effectivement que la France
n'était pas dans ce domaine-là sur un
problème de repentance assez de battre
la coupe
unilatéralement donc nous constatons en
fait que ce texte et votre argumentaire
le démontre votre argumentaire c'est de
dire ce texte ne divise pas ce qui
montre bien qu'il divise bon et bien
nous vous demandons la sagesse de feu le
président de la République socialiste
mitteran qui disait le 19 mars il faut
pas en faire une commémoration parce que
la blessure est là la blessure est
profonde et il faut faut un respect de
ceux qui sont revenus et qui aujourd'hui
encore des décennies après
pleurent je vous remercie Monsieur Louis
nèigre je n'ai pas d'autrre explication
de
vote
NON je vais donc consulter le Sénat sur
l'exception
d'recevabilité opposé par Madame Joë
garot MAM et les membres du groupe Union
pour un populaire et dont l'effet en cas
d'adoption serait d'entraîner le rejet
du texte en
discussion j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste sur la motion numéro 4 de
Madame gar Mélan tendant à l'exception
l'irrecevabilité il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront au secrétaire un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettront un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettront un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants il est
ouvert
personne de demande à voter donc le
scrutin est clos et j'invite Mesdames et
Messieurs les secrétaires à procéder au
dépouillement de ce
vote
salut
oui
ou
je vais vous donner donc le résultat du
scrutin numéro 16 sur la motion numéro 4
tendant à opposer l'exception
d'irrecevabilit à la proposition de loi
nombre de votants 342 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
340 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
171 pour l'adoption
160 contre 180 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
l'exception
d'reevabilité monsieur Marc CLH à et les
membres de l'Union du groupe de l'Union
pour un mouvement populaire ont déposé
une motion distribuée sous le numéro 1
tendant à opposer la question préalable
au texte en
discussion la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-René le cerf pour la
motion
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons ce matin
pour examiner la proposition de loi
visant à faire du 19 mars le Jour du
souvenir de la guerre d'Algérie et des
combats en Tunisie et au
Maroc une proposition de loi inscrite
par le groupe aliste au départ dans le
cadre de la Semaine d'initiative
séndatoria avant tout et en tant que
parlementaire nous ne pouvons que
constater et admirer l'engagement la
mobilisation et la pugdacité de notre
collègue Alain nerry afin que cette
proposition de loi soit inscrite à
l'ordre du jour il a engagé ce combat
pour le 19 mars il y a plus de 10 ans en
tant que commissaire aux lois j'avoue
être perplexe face à l'historique de
cette proposition loi qui est en réalité
et juridiquement parlant une petite loi
désolé pour l'intervenant précédent mais
il n'y a pas de petite commune nous le
savons bien ici effectivement ni de
petit maire nous le savons bien ici au
Sénat mais il y a effectivement des
petites lois la petites loi c'est tout
simplement la définition d'un texte qui
a été adopté par l'une des assemblées et
cela ne présente aucun jugement de
valeur sur l'importance du texte en
question ce texte a été adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale le 22 janvier
2002 l'inscription de cette proposition
de loi à l'ordre du jour par le groupe
socialiste pose mes chers collègues un
véritable problème d'éthique
parlementaire pour la seconde fois à
moins que ce ne soit la deuxième nous
verrons bien le groupe socialiste a
utilisé une tradition sénatoriale et le
règlement c'est vrai de la Haute
Assemblée permettant la saisine de
textes adoptés à l'Assemblée nationale
même lorsque celle-ci est
renouvelé si un tel usage assure la
continuité de l'action législative il
n'a probablement pas été conçu pour
exhumer une proposition de loi vieille
de plus de 10 ans d'autant mes chers
collègues que l'inverse est
impossible puisque tous les textes
déposés sur le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale deviennent caduc dès le
changement de législature est- à dire
que les textes adoptés par des députés
qui ne sont plus et précéance sur les
textes sénatoriaux sans corporatisme
aucun ce point mérite souvant mérite
pourtant d'être soulevé et il conviendra
d'y réfléchir lorsque nous songerons à
toiletter notre
règlement maintenant je souhaite vous
présenter trois raisons trois raisons
essentielles qui motivent et justifient
le dépôt de cette question
préalable
premièrement la loi du 28 février 2012 a
prévu de faire de la journée du 11
novembre
au-delà de la commémoration de la
victoire et de la paix de 1918 qu'elle
était jusqu'àors et continue d'être un
jour d'hommage à l'ensemble de ceux qui
sont morts pour la France qu'ils soi
civils ou militaires qu'ils ai péris
dans des conflits actuels ou anciens or
permettez-moi mes chers collègues de
vous rappeler que cette loi fut
rapportée par notre collègue Marcel
pierre Cléach président du groupe
d'études des sénateurs anciens
combattants il y a moins d'un an et
qu'elle fut votée à l'unanimité en
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la
défense ainsi les victimes civiles et
militaires de la guerre d'Algérie et des
combats en Tunisie et au Maroc peuvent
être et sont donc honorés le 11 novembre
comme toutes les autres victimes mortes
pour la France et cela sur la base d'un
consensus
national lequel et nous ne le dirons
jamais assez est le minimum requis pour
rendre hommage à nos aînés mort pour
notre patrie la
France
deuxièmement il existe déjà une journée
nationale spécifique d'hommage au morts
de la guerre d'Algérie et des opérations
au Maroc et en Tunisie et cette journée
c'est le 5 décembre
oui vous m'expliquerez aussi ce que
signifie le 19 mars pour les combats de
Tunisie et du
Maroc le choix de cette date est le
fruit du travail de la commission
présidé par le professeur Favier
réunissant des historiens et les
associations les plus représentative
d'anciens combattants de toutes les
guerres pour proposer une date commune
après discussion et un vote
démocratique toutes les associations
d'anciens combattants à l'exception de
la fnaka et de l'Arac ont opté pour une
date neutre celle du 5 décembre date à
laquelle avait été inauguré en 2002 le
mémorial AF F du
kbranli le 5 décembre 2002 en effet
toutes les associations et fédérations
étaient présentes dans une même
communion d'esprit autour du seul
souvenir de ceux qui avaient donné leur
vie au service de la patrie au cours de
cette période des combat d'Afrique du
Nord la volonté d'apaiser les divisions
se manifestait ainsi dans le choix d'une
date qui rassemble exemple de toute
considération politique philosophique ou
religieuse et respectant les sensibilité
de
chacun il ne s'agit il ne s'agissait ni
de commémorer une date ni de célébrer
une victoire ou de pleurer une défaite
mais simplement ce jour-là
dononorit sur l'ensemble du territoire
national la mémoire de tous ceux qui
quel que soit leur sensibilité et leurs
conviction avaient disparu dans ces
combats et ces événements on peut certes
contester le choix du 5 décembre mais on
ne peut refuser à cette date l'avantage
d'être neutre et de n'avoir d'autre but
que de rassembler autour de l'hommage du
aux
mort certes pour beaucoup le 5 décembre
ne fait aucune référence à l'histoire et
par conséquent est moins
représentatif tout Cho toutefois le
choix de cette date permet le respect de
toutes les mémoires et n'offense le
passé d'aucun des citoyens peu importe
leur appartenance ou leur statut de
l'époque et pour tous ceux qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans cette date il
reste la possibilité de se recueillir le
11 novembre mais rappelons surtout que
ceux qui souhaitent honorer leur mort le
19 mars sont tout à fait libres de le
faire sous réserve qu'il ne l'impose pas
par prosélitisme à l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale et plus
particulièrement au rapatriés arquis
supplétifs et à l'écrasante majorité des
anciens combattants lesquels ils sont
résolument hostiles dans la mesure où
cette date constitue à leurs yeux un
dénis de mémoire voire un dénis
d'honneur ainsi je vous rappelle que la
circulaire du 19 février 2009 précise
que les associations d'anciens
combattants ont la liberté et
l'initiative d'organiser des
manifestations politiques correspondant
à des anniversaires d'événements qu'ell
juge digne de
commémoration manifestations publiques
auxquelles peuvent assister les préfets
et les représentants des autorités
militaires la trème raison est une
raison qui tient plus à l'esprit qu'à la
lettre même du choix qui nous est
proposé et à notre responsabilité à nous
législateurs dev vrai pour la cohésion
nationale la portée historique du 19
mars a toujours fait en France l'objet
d'une polémique aujourd'hui cette
querelle est de nouveau prête à éclater
du fait de ce texte considéré parfois
par un certain nombre d'adhérents d'une
cinquantaine d'associations d'anciens
combattants regroupant des centaines de
milliers de membres comme je les cite
une farce lugubre ces appels au
rassemblement à la cohésion nationale
que l'on que l'on entend désormais et
très naturellement dans la bouche du
Premier ministre ne serait-il que des
paravant de mots destiné à cacher le
fait que votre majorité aurait choisi la
politisation en faisant ouvertement fi
de la réalité historique le 19 mars ne
fut pas la fin des hostilités comme il
est écrit dans l'exposé des Mo
de votre proposition de loi en
inscrivant cette proposition de loi à
l'ordre du jour de votre niche
parlementaire vous faites mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs socialistes
ouvertement le choix de légiférer au
détriment du sentiment majoritaire pour
une minorité certes très agissante et
infiniment respectable et largement
acquise à votre cause mais dont
l'opinion sur cette question est
nettement minoritaire au sein du monde
combattant depuis 1981 les présidents de
la République François miteran Jacques
Chirac Nicolas Sarkozi se sont toujours
opposés à cette reconnaissance afin de
ne pas diviser les Français en hant leur
mémoire le rôle et la responsabilité du
politique n'est-il pas de rassembler
plutôt que de diviser le rôle des élus
que nous sommes n'est-il pas de créer
les conditions d'apaisement afin que
chacun
puisse exercer sereinement son devoir de
mémoire mes chers collègues c'est son
malice que je me plais à citer François
berant qui déclarait en
1981 si une date doit être officialisée
pour célébrer le souvenir des victimes
de la guerre d'Algérie cela ne peut-être
le 19 mars car il y aura confusion dans
la mémoire de notre peuple ce n'est pas
l'acte diplomatique rendu à l'époque qui
peut s'identifier à ce qui pourrait
apparaître comme un grand moment de
notre histoire d'autant plus que la
guerre a continué que d'aut AES victimes
ont été comptées et qu'au surplus il
confient de ne froisser la conscience de
personne
oui le 19 mars était un cessé le feu
certes porteur d'espoir mais il ne fut
pas un cessé le sang alors mes chers
collègu croyez-vous vraiment nécessaire
de raviver des divisions entre les
anciens combattants ayant vécu cette
guerre alors même que nous avions
ensemble et cela honore la
représentation nationale adopté il y a
moins d'un an une solution nous
permettant d'apaiser ces
divisions notre pays n'est-il pas assez
adulte notre démocratie assez mû et
respectueuse de tous pour être capable
d'un peu de
Constance ne pensez-vous pas mes chers
collègues qu'il existe dans notre
histoire des cicatrices telles qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire de les rouvrir par
des lois
d'affichage c'est bien dans ce domaine
que nous devrions au contraire méditer
le conseil de Montesquieu de ne toucher
aux lois que d'une main tremblante
il ne s'agit pas ici de disposition
économique mais de légiférer sur ceux
qui participent de ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui puisqu'il s'agit de notre
histoire à tous ancien militaires du
contingent ou professionnel rapatriés
supplétif et arquis enfants et
petits-enfants des uns et des autres et
ce quel que soit notre famille politique
mais chers collègues ne commettons pas
une faute mémorielle en donnant à
l'histoire l'occasion de porter un jour
jugement sévère sur nos travaux on ne
peut célébrer une défaite le 19 mars
restera un divorce pour la société
française que ce soit en 1962 ou
aujourd'hui pour la communauté arquy
dont les pères et les grands-pères avait
choisi la France le 19 mars demeurera
une journée de deuil les accords des
Viion n'ont pas été respectés l'ordre du
jour du général a qui commanda l'arrêt
des combats de se concrétiser sur le
terrain que comme une mesure à sens
unique les archives dont nous disposons
dénombres tant de morts tant de blessés
tant de disparu dans les rangs de
l'armée française après le 19 mars et il
est impossible de ne pas rappeler
l'insupportable
l'effroyable massacre de dizaines de
milliers de arquis on ose à peine dire
que les chiffres varient de 60000 à
150000 tués victime des pires exactions
de la part du nouveau pouvoir et
notamment des combattant de la dernière
heure qui rejoignirent le FLN à partir
de mars
62 nous nous sommes déjà rendus
coupables de tempant d'injustice de
tempant de lâcheté de tempant de dénis
de reconnaissance vis-à-vis de nos frèr
archi est-il bien nécessaire d'en
rajouter j'ose à peine évoquer les
insultes il n'y a pas d'autre mot dont
ils furent il n'y a pas si longtemps
l'objet de la part de l'actuel chef
d'État algérien c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que je vous demande instamment
mes chers collègues d'adopter cette
question
préalable je vous remercie monsieur le
serf la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
jean-Jacques Mirassou contre la
motion monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la présidente monsieur
le
ministre mes chers
collègues beaucoup a été dit
beaucoup de choses pourrai être
partagées à ceci près que personne
personne dans les rangs de l'opposition
n'a le droit comme ça se déroule depuis
ce matin de remettre en cause la
sincérité et l'honnêteté intellectuelle
de ceux qui figurent sur ces rangs du
Sénat si je le dis c'est parce que en
dépit de toutes les démonstrations au
prix d'exercice
intellectuel un peu fastidieux ux
notamment sur ceux qui voudrai donner
des leçons de
constitutionnalité tout en évoquant du
reste la morale l'éthique la
manhonnêteté intellectuelle et que
sais-je que vous le vouliez ou non mais
chers collègues fus au prix de sanction
du Conseil constitutionnel ce qu'a
déclaré le général auré le 19 mars
1962 en déclarant le CESS le feu restera
que vous le vouliez ou non dans
l'histoire même au prix même au prix
d'une sanction du Conseil
constitutionnel
50 ans 50 ans après 50 ans après c'est
le seuil critique qui de notre point de
vue permet avec la distanciation de
l'histoire au législateur de se
déterminer en connaissance de cause et
je m'inscris en ce qui me concerne
pleinement dans les intentions affichées
par alainerie notre rapporteur qui n'ont
ni plus ni moins comme but à travers une
transmission apaisée de la mémoire
d'insturer une journée nationale du
recueillement du souvenir dédié à toutes
les victimes de ces conflits toutes les
victimes de ces conflits c'est dire que
dans les victimes que je cite il y a
bien sûr nos compatriotes rapatriés
l'éarquie mais également et surtout ceux
du
contingent 25000 décès
65000 blessés qui du jour au lendemain
ont dû quitter qu'ils habitent
s'agissant de la Haute Garonne à
Villemur sur Tarne à siadou à Revel ou à
saint-béa les uns l'USIN les autre le
champ pour aller de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée défendre une cause dont a
priori n'était pas tous convaincus de
voir quelle était la relation directe
avec leurs propres intérêts et quand ils
l'ont fait du reste mes chers collègues
quelques années après à l'occasion de la
tentative du PCH de
1963 les mêmes les mêmes derrière ce
qu'on peut appeler les officiers et les
sous-officiers légitimistes ont rendu
ces journées làà un service éminent à la
République française et à ces principes
c'est dire que même si on ne doit pas se
payer le luxe en quelque sorte de
dissocier l'ensemble des victimes
générées par ces conflits quand il est
question d'officialiser au même titre
que le 8 mai ou que le 11 novembre une
date officielle permettant à leurs
collègues survivant à leur famille de se
recueillir à leur mémoire je crois que
le Parlement à ce moment-là ACC compli
véritablement le devoir qui est le sien
alors la question préalable tendant à
opposer ce texte a participé à travers
ce qui a
été décrit récemment il y a quelques
minutes par notre collègue de ser tout
ce qui tourne depuis maintenant de
matinées que nous avons engagé ce débat
et bien sûr je redis ce que j'ai évoquer
en préambule c'est-à-dire que loin de
participer à attiser à raviv les
clivages au sein de notre sociétés et
bien et en altérant au passage l'esprit
d'union républicaine et bien ce texte
encore une fois et de notre point de vue
un texte qui a une voocation
d'apaisement alors vous le justifiez en
disant que deux lois existent celle du
23 février 2005 où je lis ce que vous
avez écrit la nation rend solement
hommage à la date du 5 décembre dont il
a été démontré que cette date était
parfaitement déconnectée d'un fait ou
d'un jour historique tel que celui que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure en ce qui
concerne le CC le feu j'en profite
également pour dire que bien entendu de
notre point de vue en évoquant ce c le
feu il n'est pas question d'induire une
une notion ou de victoire ou de défaite
mais c'est factuel qu'on le veille ou
non c'est factuel c'est ce jour-là qu' a
eu le CESS de feu et le 5 décembre
malgré les historiens paraî-il qu'il se
sont penchés sur la gestion et
l'avèement de cette date ne correspond à
rien de précis donc cet argument
effectivement ne tient pas s'agissant de
ce que vous avez évoqué par rapport au
11 novembre là on revient quand même à
un contexte beaucoup plus général où il
y a eu effectivement la tentative
d'afficher la volonté d'assurer la
promotion de mémorial D et d'éliminer ou
de diluer l'histoire de notre pays au
moment où l'autojeunesse qui se pose des
questions a besoin de repèr évidents
pour pouvoir à travers l'histoire et ces
repères et bien envisager le futur d'une
manière plus éclairée et quand vous vous
dites à plus forte raison que cette
proposition de loi tend à encombrer le
calendrier mémorial là c'est entaché
d'une manière très claire d'une
connotation péjorative par rapport à ce
que représente effectivement le 19 mars
et en ce qui nous concerne nous ne
considérons pas que les dates telles
qu'elles existent actuellement dans
notre calend
sont de nature à encombrer l'histoire
bien au contraire et c'est la raison
pour laquelle du reste nous nous
penchons actuellement sur la possibilité
et bien de assurer la promotion d'autres
dates historiques qui seraient
susceptibles et bien d'engager un volet
pédagogique par rapport à notre jeunesse
donc le calendrier mémoriel français ne
sera pas loin sans faux encombré par la
mise en place d'une célébration à
l'occasion du 19 mars
je dans le trème argument que vous avez
développé vous faites allusion à la
possibilité dédié aux associations
d'anciens combattants et à leur
initiative d'organiser des
manifestations publique c'est-à-dire que
c'est en quelque sorte quelque chose de
facultatif qui entraînerait de notre
point de vue une dévaluation de ce type
de commémoration et du reste je me
permets de vous rappeler mes chers
collègues éé fait avant moi que à
l'occasion chaque année de la
célébration du 19 mars et bien il faut
bien le dire le succès de la
participation au-delà des anciens
combattants concernés par la population
ne se dém pas si vous prenez le soin de
regarder quels sont les communes qui
affichent sur leur territoire des sites
dédiés au 19 mars vous vous rendrez
compte malgré ce que vous avez pu dire
jusqu'à présent que cette date est
inscrite dans les fêtes aussi dans la
mémoire collective de notre pays et dans
la volonté qui a été exprimée à la fois
par les conseils généraux à la fois par
les conseils régionaux et à la fois par
les communes et bien d'aller plus loin
et de l'officialiser une fois pour
toutes alors pour terminer mes chers
collègues moi je je voudrais plaider
encore une fois avec la
sincérité que nous devons à à nos
compatriotes et singulièrement à tout ce
que j'ai évoqué au début de mon
propos loin d'atiser les tensions je
pense que si nous arrivons à voter ce
textel qui sera un texte basé encore une
fois sur quelque chose de factuel et
bien ça nous permettra de tourner une
page de notre histoire et d'envisager
l'avenir dans des conditions beaucoup
plus positives en tout état de cause s'
devait y avoir qu'une raison pour voter
ce texte là c'est celle que nous devons
encore c une fois à l'ensemble des
appelés du contingent à leurs officiers
qui ont fait ce qu'ils avaient à faire
dans des conditions très difficiles et à
qui on n pas le droit on n pas le droit
de refuser cet instant privilégié à
l'occasion du 19 mars de se recueillir
sur la mémoire de ceux qui
malheureusement sont restés de l'autre
côté de la
Méditerranée je vous remercie monsieur
Mirassou quel est l'av de la Commission
sur cette
motion monsieur le Président la
Commission a donné donne un avis
défavorable mais je voudrais quand même
revenir sur quelques points très
rapidement parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites mais aussi beaucoup de
choses qui j'essaie de jeter la
confusion alors premièrement on nous dit
le 5 décembre il y a déjà une date mais
mes chers collègues mes chers amis je
veux mettre personne dans la difficulté
et surtout pas notre ami le sénateur
cléchee mais
avec Monsieur Carles ils ont envoyé un
communiqué et ce communiqué dit journée
de repentance il s'agit pas de
repentance il s'agit de rendre hommage
de rendre le moment solennel du
recueillement et du souvenir et j'auraai
pas la cruauté de vous de vous citer mes
deux chers collègues mais vous écrivez
quand même dans votre communiqué je vous
cite je l'ai là si vous voulez consulter
vous dites vous-même le 5 décembre n'a
pas de signification
historique dans le même temps vous nous
dites des historiens des historiens
disent que mais mes chers amis c'est pas
parce que des historiens disent que ça
devient forcément
historique sauf s'il disent parfois des
bêtises qui deviennent effectivement
historiques et dire que le 5 décembre
est une date historique c'est ment une
bêtise alors mes chers amis au cours des
auditions on est aperçu que tout le
monde reconnaît que le 5 décembre n'a
aucune signification historique d'autre
part vous parlez de vous parlez
de de juridiction et de vie
parlementaire reconnaissez avec nous
quand même que c'est un décret qui a
créé le 5 décembre puis il a été essayé
de le justifier à travers la loi
reconnaissez avec nous c'était un
cavalier puisqu'il s'agissait pas d'une
loi mémorielle ni historique ni rien il
s'agissait de la reconnaissance des
droit à l'indemnisation des rapatriés ce
que personne ne contestait mais ce
qu'effectivement c'était pas l'occasion
de parler de la reconnaissance de la
guerre d'Algérie et vous semblez
contester ça ça m'étonne quand même
fortement que des parlementaires arrivve
à dénigrer à dévaloriser un texte de loi
parce qu'il serait d'initiative
parlementaire mais alors vous
reconnaissez pas la valeur de votre
travail vous considérez que parce que
c'est une initiative parlementaire ça a
moins de valeur qu'un projet de loi et
je vous dirais que vous êtes en totale
contradiction puisque quel moment
quelques moment avant vous vous êtes
félicité que la guerre
d'Algérie il a fallu quand même attendre
1999 37 ans après de cesser le feu pour
reconnaître qu'enfin c'était la guerre
en Algérie et je vous dirai que c'était
une initiative parlementaire puisque
c'est la proposition de loi que j'avais
écrite et que j'avais fait adopter par
l'Assemblée nationale alors c'était donc
bien quelque chose de valeur
l'initiative parlementaire puisque vous
l'avez voté à l'unanimité donc vous êtes
en pleine
contradiction je voudrais également vous
dire que lorsque vous parlez de la 3è
génération du feu ne pas vouloir leur
accorder une journée symbolique
historique comme les deux précédentes
générations
je crois que c'est quand même quelque
chose de scandaleux parce que la 3è
génération du feu comme les deux
précédentes ont été victime ont été
l'objet d'une mobilisation générale même
si elle s'est pas faite en une seule
fois tous les de mois tous les petits
français par en Algérie mobilisé avec
son contingent et tout à l'heure notre
collègue l'a rappelé quand il revenait
quand il revenaent dans la douleur ceux
qui revenaient mais ceux qui n'est pas
c'était souvent des enterrements en
catiminiie et à la sauvette et je crois
que c'était pas l'honneur de la France
ni de ceux qui nous gouvernaient à
l'époque et ceux qui nous gouvernaient à
l'époque c'est quand même ceux qui ont
signé les accords des Viant et c'est
ceux qui n'ont pas respecté la parole de
la France vis-à-vis des archis c'est eux
qui ont donné l'ordre d'abandonner les
archis lâchement
odieusement sachant à quel sort il les
laissé sur la terre d'Algérie
et ceux qui sont revenus en France parce
qu'ils ont été accueillis en France
parce que des officiers ont osé
désobéir on n pas le quoi d'être fier
des conditions dans lesquelles on les a
reçus et je vous dirait une chose que
non seulement quand ils sont arrivés on
n pas être fier des conditions dans
lesquelles accueill mais parfois même on
les a remis dans le bateau pour les
faire repartir et quand 15 ans après
j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller à matiber là
où il y avait l'arcade du bachagabalem
et qu'on voyait dans quelles
condition ces gens ces enfants
étaient étaient malheureusement en train
de vivre on nait pas de raison d'être
fier alors je vous rappellerai quand
même que la mémoire ne doit pas être
sélective la mémoire ne doit pas être
sélective et si vous avez comme nous la
volonté de réunir toutes les douleurs
dans une même
dans une même réunion dans une même dans
un même partage si vous voulez faire que
il y a une date historique symbolique
qui est d à toutes ces victimes qui sont
morts ou qui ont souffert dans la
loyauté à la République une seule date
s'impose le 19 mars parce que celle-là
elle est
historique et mes chers amis mes chers
amis je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure il
y a pas de hiérarchisation dans la
douleur on ne fait pas ni une guerre ni
une défaite ni une victoire on se
souvient on se recueille devant la
souffrance de tous et si vous avez la
volonté
effectivement que cette souffrance soit
reconnue à dans la dignité et bien mes
chers collègues vous ne pouvez pas vous
contenter d'une date qui n'a aucune
signification c'est une insulte à tous
ceux qui ont souffert les soldats les
rapatriés les qui parce qu'ils sont tous
victimes de la même cruauté de la guerre
ils ont été tous victimes effectivement
à un moment différent avec certainement
des pensées différentes mais la nation
unanime doit se rassembler pour leur
rendre le même hommage c'est ce que nous
allons faire les douleurs qui étaient
grav dans notre chair nous devons le
graver dans le marbre de la loi c'est ce
que nous ferons
aujourd'hui je vous remercie monsieur
nia quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
sagesse j'en viens aux explications de
vote j'ai une demande de Monsieur René
garec pour le groupe UMP
Mar je ne parle pas pour le groupe je
parlerai pour
moi j'y étais moi en Algérie j'étais
soulé dedans je suis sorti sous les
dents de charerchelle le l'état économe
de ces deners sortait beaucoup
d'aspirants qui n'étaient pas payés et C
qui était payé ça faisit une grosse
différence de 30 francs à 850 francs et
quand on revenait en France en sortant
de l'école je suis reparti avec mes
vieux copains de section et j'ai dû les
quitter dans le bateau parce que moi on
me faisait voyager officier en première
classe c'est eux dans la calg parce que
l'aspirant n'était qu'un off un
sous-officier supérieur m'a expliqué les
judant ça fait partie de mes souvirs de
base je vous raconterai pas ma vie mais
je suis très mal à l'aise dans ce débat
très mal à
l'aise très mal à l'aise parce que
quand cette guerre s'est terminée
l'armistice ça n'est pas la paix et tout
ce qui a suivi a été abominable pour
ceux qui avaient vécu cela et moi je
regrettais de ne plus y être à ce
moment-là pour être avec mes amis avec
les Moras ce d'enas que je connaissais
peu les archis qui étaient avec moi mes
camarades de combat les
les Mo douel qui était le patron du
commando en face de moi à qui j'avais
dit j'écrivais des petits mot moi à sa
femme le disant rends-toi tu tu es vieux
55 ans quand je vois mon âge aujourd'hui
je rigole il s'est rendu 8 jours après
que je soit parti et j'espère qu'il
était bien accueilli par mon remplaçant
alors oui je suis très mal à l'aise
parce que je vais l'impression de faire
la guerre j'ai j'ai été un peu écorché
un peu blessé
euh pas pas assez pour être invalide
assez pour être aussi embêté que mon
torticoli d'aujourd'hui mais pas plus et
et quand je suis chez moi après ces 2
ans et demi de service militaire
l'impression que ceux qui n'avaient rien
fait av fini leur test moi j'avais pas
commencé la mienne je savais plus
comment me recycler dans ce système je
queétais pas le seul et et ça n'était
pas la guerre c'était quelque chose d'un
peu infamant d'être en Algérie et ce que
j'ai apprécié c'est la loi qui a dit et
bien l'Algérie c'était la guerre et et
la date qui sera la vôre c'est celle de
tous les anciens combattants ce sera le
11 novembre et le 11 novembre je serai
avec avec les MI pardon je pense à mes
amis l je serai avec les miens dans mon
village parce que tous les seconde
classe les sergents qui sont
là m'attendent m'ont téléphoné en disant
j'espère que tu seras là je serai là
mais ça sera le 11 novembre celle de
toute la fin la
guerre bien
je vous remercie monsieur
garek la parole est à Monsieur Marseille
pour le groupe udi C
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
rapporteur vous en douter nous voterons
cette question préalable j'ai écouté
avec
intérêt les propos de notre collègue
Mirassou et je trouve que notre
assemblée prend un risque avec ce choix
qui est discuté
aujourd'hui on a parlé de la
responsabilité que devait prendre le
Sénat et le Parlement dans le choix de
cette date cette date fait débat elle
aurait peut-être déjà été adoptée sinon
et pourquoi on a choisi le 5 décembre
c'est justement parce qu'elle faisait de
peine ni aux uns ni aux autres et donc à
force aujourd'hui on dit elle ne
correspond à rien évidemment alors on
dit le Parlement va trancher sagesse
c'est possible mais à ce moment-là on
peut pas avoir une i quand il s'agit du
génocide des Arméniens et dire que il
faut laisser le temps au temps et il
faut faire travailler les historien
saisir le cas échéant comme beaucoup
l'ont fait le Conseil
constitutionnel et lire les propos
talentueux de notre ancien collègue
Badinter et puis quand il s'agit du 19
mars dire il appartient au Parlement de
trancher ça veut dire qu'au gré des
majorité chacun pourra aujourd'hui
demain et à l'avenir évidemment proposer
des dates euh qui seront portées de
bonne foi avec honnêteté par des
convictions mais qui ne seront pas des
dates partagées qui ne seront pas des
dates consensuelles c'est un risque que
nous prenons mes chers collègues et je
pense que nous nous devons être très
prudents c'est la raison pour laquelle
une nouvelle fois notre groupe votera la
question
préalable bien je vous
remercie
je vous rappelle qu'il n'y a qu'une
explication par
groupe donc la parole est à Monsieur
Alain Richard pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le
Président comme beaucoup
ici je me sens touché par ce débat et je
partage sous une certaine forme le
malaise de René
garek à la
différence des dates commémoratives qui
font aujourd'hui partie de notre
histoire le 11 novembre et le 8
mai cette date du 19 mars est celle d'un
cess le feu à l'issue d'une guerre
d'indépendance le 11 novembre et le 8
mai c'était l'armistice à l'issue d'une
guerre de défense du pays c'est ce qui
explique les sentiments partagés qui
s'expriment
aujourd'hui c'est une place toute
particulière dans l'histoire de notre
pays et c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour
laquelle on peut argumenter pour le 19
mars commémoration des conflits au Maroc
en Tunisie et en Algérie puisque à des
degrés d'intensité de violence divers la
France a
combattu contre
l'indépendance de trois de ces anciennes
colonies ou
protectorat donc
moi je veux essayer d'exprimer avec le
plus grand respect un désaccord
avec l'argumentation de la la question
préalable et notamment je vis insister
sur deux points qui ont été évoqué par
notre collègue Jean-René
lecer le premier c'est
que ce conflit là c'est le dernier où
des appelés du contingent combattu pour
la
France le dernier j'espère pour
longtemps il se trouve que les hasards
de la vie publique ont fait que j'ai
participé au gouvernement qui a intégré
l'administration des anciens combattant
dans la défense ce qui me semble être
l'aboutissement naturel et honorable de
cette phénomène social qu'ont été les
vétérans dans notre pays et qu'il
reste que j'ai participé au gouvernement
qui a mis fin à la conscription sur la
base d'une décision prise antérieurement
par le président Chirac et qui s'est
fororcé
d'organiser correctement une défense
professionnalisée et que c'est le
gouvernement qui a aussi consacré on a
rappelé le rôle important joué par mon
ami Jean-Pierre Masseret
la reconnaissance de la guerre d'Algérie
en tant que
telle il me semble que cette génération
de combattants qui ont combattu sous les
ordres d'officiers pour certains
professionnels pour beaucoup appeler
aussi à droit à ce que soit reconnu son
apport à l'honneur du pays et à sa
défense y compris dans une une guerre
dans un conflit armé dont sur lequel
nous ne pouvons pas avoir la même vision
historique que celle des conflits de 141
et de 39 45 nous les appelons tous et
nous les honorons comme la 3è génération
du feu en tant que génération d'appeler
c'est la dernière nous le
savons donc il peut y avoir partage dans
les
opinions nous savons tous et de voir
dans quelle ville existe des rues ou des
places du 19 mars nous savons tous quel
que soi nos différences
politiques que eux souhaitent ceux qui
ont combattu la date du 19 mars et pas
une
autre du point de vue de la légitimité
et de l'appel à l'honneur il me semble
que cette date a de réelles
justification la deuxème observation que
je voudrais faire est relative au vote
unanime qui est intervenu sur la la le
projet de loi permettant une
commémoration des victimes de l'ensemble
des conflits je n'en ai pas du tout la
même lecture que Jean-René
leer il y avait on était en plus en
période de forte tension politique je ne
dis rien
d'autre et il y avait un débat qui vous
le savez très bien suscitait une réelle
émotion dans l'ensemble du monde
combattant sur l'idée qui avait déjà été
évoquée il y a fort longtemps par le
président jcardestin de réunion en une
seule date de la commémoration de
l'ensemble des
conflits et donc nous étions dans
l'opposition à ce moment-là et nous
avons été plusieurs à voir le risque
d'un clivage sur ce sujet qui é
évidemment à
éviter et donc grâce à quelques
réflexion qu'on eu les uns les autres un
amendement qui permettait de rappeler
que cette
date ne mettrait fin à aucune autre
commémoration a permis le rassemblement
et l'unanimité et j'ai attacher la plus
grande importance du fait des fonctions
que que j'ai exercé et de l'attachement
que je conserve à la communauté
militaire parce que nous avions besoin
en effet d'une date pour commémorer le
sacrifice des professionnels de la
nouvelle défense
française donc nous sommes arrivés au
rassemblement sur ce sujet pour ce
motif-là parce que nous étions tous
convaincus qu'il fallait trouver une
date qui permettait d'honorer la mémoire
des soldats d'aujourd'hui des soldats
professionnels tombés en opération
extérieure en revanche si l'idée avait
été de dire à travers ce choix nous
éliminons le débat sur la commémoration
de la guerre d'Algérie nous savons tous
qu'il n'y aurait pas eu unanimité donc
il me semble qu'il vaut mieux que nous
nous rassemblions dans le respect mutuel
encore une fois pour reconnaître le
caractère de consécration d'une
génération du feu et ses souffrances au
combat avec le 19 mars plutôt que
d'aller chercher des argumentaires qui
me semble-t-il ne correspondent pas à la
réalité et à la gravité des événements
je vous
remercie je vous remerci chers collègu
je n'ai pas d'autrees explication de
vote je vais donc consulter le Sénat sur
la question préalable opposé par
Monsieur Marcel pierre cléache et les
membres du groupe Union pour un
mouvement populaire et dont l'adoption
aurait pour effet d'entraîner le rejet
du texte en
discussion donc j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste sur la motion numéro 1
concerné je vous rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est défavorable et que le
gouvernement a émis un avis de sagesse
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement et ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettront au
secrétaire un bulletin blanc ceux qui
souhaitent voter contre remettront un
bulletin blanc et ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir remettront un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera donc ouvert dans
quelques
instants
le scrutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos et
j'invite messieurs les secrétaires à
procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
je vais vous donner donc résultat du
scrutin numéro 17 sur la motion numéro 1
rectifiée tendant à opposer la question
préalable à la proposition de loi nombre
de votants
342 nombre de suffrages exprimés 340
majorité absolue des suffrage exprimé
171 pour l'adoption
157 contre
183 le Sénat n'a pas adopté la question
au
préalable euh mes chers collègues nous
allons commencer le débat sur l'article
1er mais je vous informe que je dois
suspendre la séance vers
11h55 pour la cérémonie d'hommage au
sénateur et aux fonctionnaires morts
pour la France qui est prévu à à 12h en
haut de l'escalier d'honneur
euh donc
je pense on commence les articles oui
n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient oui on reprend bien sûr
après on reprend après jusqu'à
13h on reprend vers 12h10 pour aller
jusqu'à 13h alors nous entamons les
prises de parole si vous en êtes
d'accord bien bien donc à l'article 1er
il y a une prise de parole par Monsieur
R pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le
Président plus de 22000 communes
commémore le 19 mars aujourd'hui en
France je crois que c'est un cas assez
unique de notre histoire mémorielle
républicaine où le devoir de mémoire
s'est exprimé d'abord à partir de la
population et de ces témoins cette
demande de témoignage est venue des
communes le socle premier de nos
institutions qui sont très nombreuses
maintenant à avoir une rue une place qui
porte le nom du 19 mars
1962 il est grand temps mes chers
collègues que la République établisse
une date commémorative afin que la
nation toute entière s'unisse dans un
même devoir de mémoire il est plus que
temps que nous puissions parler de
l'Algérie sans ne plus diviser mais nous
unir c'est vrai il y a eu une difficulté
de la guerre d'Algérie à faire mémoire
compte tenu de l'épreuve douloureuse
qu'elle a représenté pour les militaires
et les appelés du contingent les
Français d'Algérie et les archis mais je
rappelle que 2 millions de soldats ont
traversé la Méditerranée entre 1955 et
1962 dont une majorité d'appeler or il y
a un principe de notre re devoir
mémoriel républicain exprimé à l'origine
par George clémenau qui disait ceux qui
ont combattu qui ont été blessés qui
sont morts pour avoir fait leur devoir
en répondant à l'appel de la République
ont des droit sur nous oui les grands
rendez-vous mémoriels sont l'occasion de
rappeler les sacrifices consentis par le
monde combattant c'est à partir d'eux
que la République pour tous les conflits
et établit le socle de son devoir
mémoriel sans pour autant exclure les
autres victimes notamment les victimes
civiles qui ont aussi et par ailleurs
droit à réparation c'est bien à ces
soldats et ses appelés que s'adressait
le CC le F du 19 mars
1962 décidé par la République il
signifiait à travers eux que la
République n'était plus engagée dans les
combats et que la France n'était plus en
guerre
une guerre qui a coûté la vie à plus de
25000 militaires majoritairement appelé
ou rappelé du contingent non
effectivement ce n'est pas la date ABR
cadabrantesque du 5 décembre on dira
arbitraire également qui peut constituer
ce rendez-vous mémoriel car ce jour du 5
décembre n'est en fait que la
saintgéralde et rien d'autre oui nous
considérons que seul la reconnaissance
du CC le feu officiel du 19 mars
1962 approuvé à l'époque par plus de 90
% des Français par référendum est à même
de marquer solennellement la
reconnaissance qui est d à ceux dont la
loyauté à l'égard de la République n'a
pas fait défaut certes nous le savons il
y a eu ensuite la tragédie desarquis qui
est une tâche sombre dans notre his
mais n'oublions pas qu'il y a eu après
le 19 mars des Français d'Algérie aussi
tuer et massacré mais il faut voir dans
le 19 mars une date républicaine qui
doit rappeler à tous les Français le
devoir de justice et de vérité que la
nation entreprend et respectter
vis-à-vis des aements de la colonisation
et des conséquences de la guerre et des
combats qui en ont été le prolongement
notre rôle ici est de rappeler que le 19
mars est le jour où la République a
entrepris un choix pour toute la nation
en ouvrant le temps d'une autre séquence
de son destin collectif oui il peut y
avoir eu dans la mémoire des uns et des
autres des guerres d'Algérie en revanche
il y a eu un drame algérien pour toute
la République pour tous ses enfants
c'est pour cela que la République a le
devoir de rassembler ses enfants c'est
ce que propose aujourd'hui cette
proposition de loi enfin la date du 19
mars est aussi un pont entre les
différentes mémoires cette date nous
renvoie à notre devoir de construire une
relation équilibrée apaisée et exigeante
avec la République Algérienne le 19 mars
nous fournis donc la possibilité de
partir du singulier de l'événement du
particulier des vécu et des histoires
personnelles pour rendre justice à la
collectivité pour ellmême et aux yeux de
tous c'est à chaque fois que la
République réussit cette démarche de
synthèse que la nation se trouve grandie
et peut tirer de ce moment collectif de
commémoration que peut constituer le 19
mars ce qui la fortifie pour son avenir
je vous
remercie et la parole est à Monsieur
michel Teston pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers et chers collègues nous
sommes appelés à nous prononcer
aujourd'hui sur la proposition de loi
relative à la reconnaissance du 19 mars
comme journée nationale du souvenir et
de recueillement à la mémoire de toutes
les victimes civiles et militaires de la
guerre d'Algérie et des combats en
Tunisie et au Maroc texte qui a été
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale en
janvier 2002 il aura donc fallu 10 ans à
la représentation nationale pour
reconnaître officiellement la date du 19
mars comme journée nationale de souvenir
et de
recueillement de 1954 à 1962 la guerre
d'Algérie a causé des dizaines de
milliers de morts des centaines de
milliers de blessés avec aujourd'hui
encore de nombreuses personnes
traumatisées sous le gouvernement de
Lyonel Jospin avec la loi du 18 octobre
1999 texte d'origine parlementaire le
Parlement a enfin reconnu que ce que
l'on appelit piquement les événements
d'Algérie étaiit une guerre jusqu'à
cette date on parlait officiellement je
cite de simples opérations de maintien
de l'ordre en Afrique du Nord fin de
citation grâce à la loi de
1999 voté à ma connaissance à
l'unanimité dans les deux assemblées la
réalité a été enfin reconnue la la
guerre d'Algérie est bel et bien une
guerre aujourd'hui c'est la date du 19
mars qui va devenir journée nationale je
cite de recueillement et de mémoire en
souvenir de toutes les victimes de la
guerre d'Algérie des combats en Tunisie
au Maroc et de tous leur
drame alors le choix de la date de
commémoration a fait l'objet vous le
savez toutes et tous de débats très
nombreux depuis de nombreuses années
pour ma part j'ai toujours considéré
qu'il fallait retenir la date du 19 mars
si chacun d'entre nous le sait la date
du 19 mars n'a pas marqué la fin réelle
des hostilités il n'en demeure pas moins
que cette date est essentielle car elle
est celle du cesser le feu entre la
France et le FLN cette date a donc une
signification historique forte
contrairement par exemple à celle du 5
décembre qui n'a aucun lien historique
avec les combats d'Afrique du Nord cette
cette date est en outre souhaitée par
une majorité d'anciens combattants de la
3e génération du feu comme l'a dit notre
collègue Alain nry la guerre d'Algérie
est restée trop longtemps une guerre
sans nom elle ne peut rester sans date
historique et symbolique avec cette date
historique et symbolique nousous
souvenons de celles et de ceux qui ont
perdu la vie nous soutenons celles et
ceux qui ont été meurtris dans leur
chair nous exerçons chers et chers
collègues tout simplement notre devoir
de
mémoire je vous remercie monsieur Teston
la parole est à Monsieur Gérard
Larcher monsieur le président monsieur
le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues le 25 octobre dernier il
s'agissait de débattre dans le cadre de
l'ordre du jour de réservé d'une
proposition loi qui qu'on le veuille ou
non est clivante pour le monde
combattant une proposition de loi
adoptée par une représentation nationale
issue d'élection de
1997 et qui ravive des blessure encore
profonde au sein de notre société et
cela au détriment d'un principe qui me
semble essentiel pour toutes les
commémorations et hommag principe
d'apaisement que notre nation se doit de
rendre à ceux et celles qui se sont
sacrifiés pour elle no débat de ce matin
montre combien l'apaisement est encore
un chemin à parcourir
oui le 19 mars est une date qui pouron
nombre de nos concitoyens et leurs
descendants est encore synonyme de
douleur et de drame notre collègue
Jean-René le cerf l'a évoqué ce matin en
plus me semble-t-il d'être inopportun
pour la cohésion de toute la nation ce
texte revient sur deux lois qui ont fait
l'objet d'examen et de votes dans des
délais raisonnable celle du 23 février
2005 voulu par le président Jacques
Chirac portant reconnaissance de la
Nation et contribution nationale en
faveur des Français rapatriés et qui
rend un hommage solenel aux combattants
morts pour la France en Afrique du Nord
bien sûr j'ai entendu et je viens
d'entendre que cette date fait référence
à
aucun moment de l'histoire toutefois
cette date permet le respect de toutes
les mémoires ne meurtris pas ce qui est
essentiel quand on parle de cohésion
nationale le passé le souvenir d'aucun
des citoyens et peu importe leur
appartenance politique leur statut à
l'époque l'origine et leur choix le 5
décembre offre à la nation l'occasion
d'un moment de recueillement républicain
et dommage apaisé aujourd'hui proposant
le 19 mars même si cela répond à la
demande de deux associations que je
respecte contre l'avis de 40 autres que
Monsieur nerry il faut aussi écouter et
respecter vous balayez le travail
accompli depuis 2005 et le chemin
parcouru par nombre d'associations et de
familles sur la route d'une mémoire
nationale rassemblée alors que les
événements d'Algérie sont encore des
temps de mémoire douloureux vous revenez
également sur la loi du 28 février 2012
cette commémoration de tous les morts
pour la France celle bien sûr et nous
venons de le faire tous ensemble du
souvenir des 14 188 et des 39 45 celle
aussi de ceux qui ont combattu en
Algérie mais je voudrais évoquer
l'Indochine personne n'en a parlé la
mémoire de celles et de ceux qui sont
tombés pour la France en Indochine elle
mérite un temps de rassemblement et ce
temps de rassemblement le 5 décembre
nous l'offre sur ceux qui sont tombés
sur les théâtres d'opération extérieur
oui un 11 novembre qui permet une
transcendance des valeurs de notre pays
alors monsieur le ministre je m'adresse
à vous en ayant inscrit cette
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour du
gouvernement l'exécutif et je reprends
vos mots du 25 octobre aujourd'hui
s'ingère et interfère puisqu'il s'ingère
je voudrais savoir Monsieur le Ministre
si le gouvernement il peut le faire
entant saisir l'Assemblée nationale de
l'éventuel texte qui sortirait de nos
travaux d'aujourd'hui ceci me paraît une
démarche
indispensable aujourd'hui que nos
collègues issus de l' de des élections
de juin dernier puisse avoir à connaître
de ce texte et je souhaite savoir quelle
est l'intention du gouvernement à ce
sujet mais notre collègue Joë gara l'a
rappelé avec d'autres le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui se situe dans un
contexte différent de celui du 25
octobre le mardi 30 octobre le ministre
des Anciens Combattants de la République
populaire et algérienne sherff Abbas a
souhaité de la part de la France une
reconnaissance franche des CRIM perpétré
à leur rcontre par le colonialisme
français une fois encore ces propos ont
placé sous tension les relations
franco-algérienne et place sous de
difficiles hospices le voyage que je
juge
indispensable du président de la
République à Alger les 19 et 20 décembre
prochains cette proposition mis à
l'ordre du jour du gouvernement ne peut
être ressenti comme une réponse à une
injonction extérieure la mémoire
nationale 50 ans après doit d'abord être
un rassemblement et une unité elle ne
peut être instrumentalisé en aucune
manière la véritable conciliation des
mémoires françaises et algériennes ne
peut se faire sur la stigmatisation des
uns et le partiprix des autres la
mémoire de l'Algérie celle de 1830 en à
1962 en France comme en Algérie
nécessite dialogue objectivité respect
mutuel travail préalable conjoint
d'historien comme l'avait proposé le
président de la République Jacques
Chirac dans le cadre de la préparation
du traité d'amitié entre la France et
l'Algérie qui malheureusement n'a jamais
été signé al alors le choix du 19 mars
me paraît contraire à cette exigence de
dialogue d'objectivité et de respect
mutuel pour le l'unité et la mémoire de
toute la nation ce texte doit être
retiré je remercie Monsieur
Larcher la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Pierre
Charon monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues avant de revenir sur le fond
de cette proposition de loi je
souhaiterais comme beaucoup l'ont fait
avant moi vous faire part de ma
consternation devant les méthodes du
gouvernement et ma tristesse de voir le
mépris avec lesquel sont traités nos
institutions c'est pourtant bien vous
monsieur le ministre qui avez ouvert nos
débats le 25 octobre dernier en vous
remettant à la sagesse de notre haute
assemblée dans le plein respect des
prérogatives du Parlement car c'est à ce
dernier qu'il incombe achev un processus
législatif qu'il a lui-même engagé et ce
sans doute sans toute ingérence ni
interférence de la part d'exécutif merci
pour ses propos monsieur le ministre il
est dès lors incompréhensible que
l'ordre du jour a été bousculé comme il
l'a été pour essayer de faire passer en
force comme cela semble devenir
l'habitude si certains d'entre nous
avaient encore des doutes quant aux
sombres arrière-pensé politicienn qui
motivent l'exhumation de ce texte je
pense qu'ils seront éclairés par ces
méthode qui n'annonce pas les plus
belles heures de la
démocratie l'article 1 du texte qui nous
est présenté aujourd'hui vise à créer
une journée nationale à la mémoire des
victimes civiles et militaires de la
guerre d'Algérie et des combats en
Tunisie et au Maroc cela pose une
première question pourquoi pourquoi
instituer une journée nationale alors
qu'elle existe déjà permettez-moi chers
collègues de rappeler le décret du 26
septembre 2003 instituant une journée
nationale d'hommage aux morts pour la
France pendant la guerre d'Algérie et
les combat du Maroc et de la Tunisie le
5 décembre de chaque année ce décret
sera d'ailleurs suivi d'un certain
nombre d'avancées législatives t la loi
du 23 février 2005 complété le 7 mars
dernier grâce à l'adoption de la
proposition de loi déposée par notre
collègue Raymond couder enfin la loi du
28 février 2012 fixant au 11 novembre la
commémoration de tous les morts pour la
France de Verdin à capissa comme je
l'avais alors formulé il y a plusieurs
raison possible à cette volonté de
remettre aujourd'hui la main dans
l'histoire et de sceller la mémoire du
conflit algérien du 19 mars je préfère
ne pas imaginer la première qui
tiendrait au fait que le décret en
question date de 2003 début du 2e mandat
de Jacques Chirac et du gouvernement de
notre éminent collègue Jean-Pierre
rafarin si vous n'êtes donc pas inspiré
par la jalousie politique peut-être
est-ce par simple méconnaissance des
événements qui ensanglantire la France
et l'Algérie pendant 8 ans aussi je
tiens chers collègues à rappeler les
conditions doulour de la fin de ce
conflit qui exclut évidemment
l'opportunité de cette date pour en
cristalliser la mémoire le 19 mars 62 ce
ne fut pas la fin d'une tragédie mais le
début d'un long cauchemar cette
signature n'est malheureusement pas du
tout le CESS le feu promis et attendu
c'est une signature vide qui a été
trahie le jour même par le FLN laissant
une blessure ouverte dans la mémoire de
ce conflit par ailleurs une semaine plus
tard le 26 mars 62 des civils français
non armés partis an du statut quo
manifeste devant la Grande Poste de la
rue disli ils seront mitraillés par
l'armée française maises chers collègues
la comparaison qui est faite avec les
dates du 11 novembre et du 8 mai est
particulièrement choquante en effet
comment comparer le 11 novembre 1918
armistice victorieux qui signe le retour
de la paix dans notre pays le 8 mai 45
victoire des alliés sur l'Allemagne
nazie rassemblant la France avec
elle-même après la déchirure de l'
passion et le 19 mars qui n'est pas un
amnistice mais une trahison le jour même
du FLN qui a profité de la situation
pouronstituer ses forces armées
massacrer les archis et lancer une
campagne d'enlèvement de français rester
en Algérie alors un cess le feu certes
mais comme le disait Jean-René le sererf
tout à l'heure certainement pas un cess
le sang en choisissant cette date des
accords déviant comme symbole national
on oublie et quelque part on méprise les
civils et les militaires morts après le
19 mars 62 je ne peux accepter que soit
dénaturée la position du général de
Gaulle dans cet épisode de notre
histoire oui la raison inspira au
général cette issue douloureuse et
nécessairement imparfaite au conflit
algérien mais nous savons que son cœur
lui soufflait pourtant fidèlement tous
français de dunkererque à Tamanrasset
oui l'histoire a amené le peuple
algérien à disposé librement de lui-même
et il n'est évidemment pas question de
revenir aujourd'hui sur cette idée et
sur ce mouvement de l'histoire mais
l'acceptation de cette réalité ne doit
pas nous conduire à transformer une
blessure en fait nationale notre
histoire est un bien précieux elle est
faite de conquête de rêve et de bataille
elle est faite de victoire et de
défaites elle est fait d'héroïsme et de
souffrance il ne s'agit pas de nier les
fêtes mais il ne viendrait pas à l'idée
de quelqu'un de fêter Sedan ou bien di
benfou aussi comment peut-on aujourd'hui
imaginer célébrer une défaite qui est
fêtée comme une victoire en Algérie
voilà pourquoi mes chers collègues je ne
peux ni comprendre ni accepter le choix
de cette date qui loin de refermer la p
La ravive et la Creuse je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur
Charon la parole est maintenant à Madame
Joë garot
Mélin mes chers collègues le chef de
l'État et son prier ministre revendique
la concertation comme marque de fabrique
du gouvernement or aujourd'hui que nous
demandeons de faire d'adopter un texte
sur lequel nos collègues députés
n'auront pas leur mots à dire puisque
l'on présume qu'un vote vieux de 10 ans
est toujours valable et alors même que
certains des députés qui ont voté pour
ce texte en 2002 vont aujourd'hui le
voter à nouveau cette fois en tant que
sénateur nous l'avons dit c'est en
particulier votre cas cher àerie dont je
note la persévérance à soutenir cette
proposition de loi passant de
l'Assemblée au Sénat et la commission
des affaires étrangères à celle des
affaires sociales certes je n'ai pas
trouvé très
convaincante vos contorions sémantique
mais c'est surtout l'absence le manque
de consultation du monde combattant qui
m'inquiète et me gêne fortement en 2003
le choix de la date du 5 décembre pour
institué une journée de mage avait été
retenu justement parce qu'il était
soutenu par une très large majorité
d'association d'anciens combattants seul
deux associations lui préférant la date
du 19 mars comme l'a opportunément
rappeler Gérard Larcher cette fois la
méthode inverse a été retenue très
certainement parce qu'une concertation
plus large n'aurait pas permis de
dégager de consensus ou même de simple
majorités en FA faveur de la date du 19
mars alors que cette proposition de loi
était inscrite il y a plus d'un mois à
l'ordre du jour le rapporteur n'a jugé
nécessaire de rencontrer que quatre
associations parmi la quarantaine qu'en
compte le monde combattant la fnaka et
la rac les deux seules associations qui
militent pour une commémoration
nationale le 19 mars compte à peine plus
de 300000 membres alors que les 40
associations qui s'y opposent
représentent plus de 2 millions de
familles je trouve vraiment scandaleux
indigne que quatre audition suffise à
légitimer une proposition aussi sensible
que
clivante alors oui bien sûr mes chers
collègues il y a eu un cess le feu le 19
mars personne ne le
conteste je vais même vous dire parce
que nous avons laissé une liberté de
vote dans notre groupe UMP que c
certains de nos collègues nous ont dit
vouloir célébrer cette date parce qu'ils
se souviennent de la joie qu'ils ont
ressenti alors oui bien sûr qui ne
serait heureux de la fin d'une guerre
mais comment comment
oser honorer nos morts à une date qui a
été une journée de dupe qui est
aujourd'hui encore une PL béante pour
des millions de personnes
comment oublier tous les morts qui ont
suivi comment oublier tous ces humbles
enlev supplicier comment oublier surtout
tous ces archis qui ont péri parce
qu'ils croyaient en la France et envers
qui nous avons mes chers amis une dette
d'honneur vous avez mentionné monsieur
le rapporteur l'existence de rue du 19
mars vous avez même mentionné le
bouchagoualem alors je voudrais vous
dire t simplement la honte que j'ai
ressenti quand une municipalité
socialiste a débaptisé une rue du qui
portait le nom du
bouchagaaboualem alors je vais vous le
dire vraiment pour moi imposer cette
date du 19 mars ce serait une nouvelle
trahison une trahison envers les
rapatriés une trahison envers les arquis
une trahison envers les associations
combattantes qui dans leur majorité sont
contre cette date du 19 mars vous avez
dit aussi qu'il fallait réconcilier le
monde combattant et les Français mais
alors comment osez-vous proposer cette
date vous êtes en contradiction totale
avec vous-même vraiment par égard pour
eux par égard pour la France par égard
pour notre haute assemblée par respect
pour toutes ces victimes de cette guerre
d'Algérie vous vous honoreriez mes chers
collègu à ne pas défendre une telle
proposition de
loi
je vous remercie madame gar
m la parole est maintenant à
Mademoiselle Sophie
joissant monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues tout d'abord je tiens à
associer mon collègue et ami Bruno Gill
à l'ensemble des propos que je vais
tenir ici devant vous pour répondre à
l'objectif de l'article 1er de cette
proposition de loi deux textes ont déjà
été
adoptés
le 23 février 2005 portant
reconnaissance de la Nation et
contribution nationale en faveur des
Français rapatriés il a été modifié le 7
mars 2012 pour sanctionner pénalement
tout un jure envers les supplés de
l'armée
française cette loi é étendue à
l'ensemble des supplectifs de l'armée
française mais il est à noter et c'est
important pour la suite qu'elle a été
prise principalement pour protéger les
archis AR qui ont massivement été
massacré à partir du 19 mars
cette loi qui a été adoptée à la quasi
unanimité d'entre nous a prévu une
commémoration le 5 décembre pourquoi
cette date parce qu'elle est neutre et
dans sa neutralité permet le respect de
toutes les mémoires elle n'offense le
passé d'aucun citoyen quel que soi ses
appartenances politiques et les choix
que lui-même ou ses ascendants ont pu
faire lors de conflits douloureusement
fratricid par ce Biel remplit pleinement
l'objectif d'unité du peuple français
d'apaisement de la douleur des mémoires
et s'inscrit sur le chemin de la
réconciliation de ceux ont été divisés
déchirés par les conflits
d'indépendance la seconde loi loi du 28
février 2012 fixe au 11 novembre la
commémoration de tous les morts pour la
France
elle a été votée par le groupe
socialiste et le groupe UMP le 24
janvier 2012 elle permet d'honorer
l'ensemble de ceux qui se sont battus et
sont morts pour la France de nos plus
anciens comme les poilus au plus récents
nos soldats partis lors d'opérations
extérieur et notamment en
Afghanistan cette loi votée encore une
fois presque par tous va comme le texte
précédent dans le sens de la cohésion
nationale du devoir de mémoire et de
l'Union
républicaine ces dates ont été prises
non pas pour correspondre à rien mais
pour honorer le courage et la mémoire de
tous nos combattants elles ont été
choisies dans un souci de respect de
dignité et d'honneur vis-à-vis de ceux
de tous ceux qui se sont battus pour la
France ce n'est pas le cas de la date du
19 mars pour ma part le groupe et pour
le groupe um les commémorations du 5
décembre et du 11 novembre remplissent
du mieux possible les revendications des
anciens combattants d'Algérie de Tunisie
et du Maroc etell les unissent sans
clivé surtout ce qui paraît inimaginable
sans risquer de porter insulte et
ultrage au souvenirs de ceux qui ont été
massacrés et malheureusement il faut le
rappeler que la France n'a pas défendu
l'association qui demande la
reconnaissance commémorative de la date
du 19 mars représente 358500 adhérents
un autre collectif associatif ulcéré de
cette proposition de loi comprend 43
associations et compte 1200000
adhérents je vais vous lire une partie
du communiqué qu'ils ont
adressé le 19 mars ne peut pas être une
date de recueillement car il rappelle et
pour trop de Français le deuil et
l'exode s'entenir au 19 mars serait
bafoué la mémoire des dizaines de
milliers de harquis massacré après cette
date comme celle du millions de nos
compatriotes victimes d'une véritable
épuration ethnique faut-il rappeler
qu'il s'agissait notamment de
descendants révolutionnaires de 1848 des
patriotes d'Alsace laorine enfin des
anciens républicains espagnols exilés
refusant la dictature et tous ceux qui
se sont engagés plus que d'autres dans
les campagnes de la libération de la
France entre 43 et 45 c'est aussi leur
voix qu'il faut écouter c'est celle des
Français lorsque la nation a voulu
honorer ceux qui ont donné leur vie pour
la France dans tous les conflits le
Parlement à sa très grande majorité a
voté le 28 février dernier une loi que
l'on peut qualifier de mémoriel certes
retenant le 11 novembre comme journée de
commémoration pour tous les morts pour
la France cette loi exclut la
suppression de commémorations existantes
officielle comme associative une
nouvelle loi serait superféatoire venant
notamment de sénateurs qui avaient voté
la loi du 28 février dernier aussi le
report de cette discussion s'avère une
opportunité à saisir pour s'interroger
sur son bien fondé en s'inspirant de
personnalités aussi différentes que le
général de Gaulle François mitteran qui
l'un comme l'autre avait refusé cette
date chaque sénateur devrait pouvoir
s'exprimer en son âme et conscience soit
rejeter cette proposition de loi au nom
de l'unité d'une mémoire collective
apaisée confirmant le sens du vote de
février dernier soit choisir de
réveillir une division profonde entre
Français de toute catégorie de toutes
origines en la votant pour satisfaire
une fraction minoritaire du monde
combattant une telle loi mémorielle
votée à courte majorité serait certes
légal mais sans légitimité faute de
consensus
national c'est le mondre des anciens
combattants qui parl ce n'est pas
moi le conflit en Algérie date
aujourd'hui de 50 ans et pourtant il
suffit de voir le nombre d'associations
de Français rapatriés et de archis pour
mesurer la profondeur des blessures qui
subsistent
l'apaisement avec l'Algérie doit aussi
se faire pour eux et avec eux monsieur
Cader Harif ministre délégué aux anciens
combattants dans une interview datant du
octobre il est inacceptable par exemple
que nos compatriotes archis ne puissent
pas se rendre dans le pays de leurs
ancêtres ou pour ceux qui le souhaitent
y être enterré ce serait effectivement
très beau nous avons abordé cette
question avec nos amis algériens et nous
avons compris qu'il y avait une volonté
d'ouverture de leur part à ce sujet la p
peut-être en bonne VO croyez-vous
vraiment excusez-moi je vous ai pas
interrompu croyez-vous vraiment qu'en
adoptant une date de
commémoration qui été le signal du
massacre de leurs conclure veuillez
conclure chers collèguesqu auront envie
de se rendre sur cette terre qui celle
de leurs ancêtres cela serait peut-être
pour eux une immense
humiliation on évalue le nombre de leurs
morts à partir du 19 mars mort dans des
conditions atroces entre 60 et 00
victimes de même pour les familles de
piedsnoirs plus de 3000 personnes ont
été enlevées et jamais retrouvé à ce
jour le traité d'amitié avec l'Algérie
doit se faire dans un respect mutuel et
non au prix de l'humiliation de nos
consitoyens qui ont déjà conclu chers
collègues je voudrais juste rajouter un
élément j'ai bien écouté attentivement
vos propos et je pense qu'il y a une
manœuvre gouvernementale derrière qui
qui me paraît évidente mais mais mais
mais au-delà de ça j'ai reconnu aussi
des accents de sincérité Ré et je pense
notamment au rapporteur néanmoins il y a
une chose qui m'a qui m'a saisi c'est
que les argument qui était parfois
développé aurait très bien pu aboutir à
la conclusion d'écarter la loi du 19
mars parce que je cro qu'on
pas juste une phrase je crois qu'on ne
peut pas décider de la manière de vivre
la douleur que l'on ressent pour
d'autres et je pense que 1 million de de
personnes
combattant son contre il n'est pas en
notre devoir de pouvoir leur imposer
cela merci chers
collèg la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Jean-Pierre
s monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
rapporteur madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers
collègues je voulais vous apporter un
témoign
depuis 31 ans je suis élu d'un
département de ce pays d'abord comme
député puis comme maire puis comme
sénateur j'ai participé à des centaines
de réunion me rendant chaque fois que je
le pouvais à toutes les assemblées des
ancien combattants quel qu'ell soit car
je considère que dès lors que nous
sommes appel nous les élus de la nation
ou les élus des collectivités locales à
venir nous recueillir devant les
monuments rappelant ceux qui sont morts
pour la France nous devons nous y
rendre il m'est arrivé il y a
longtemps lors d'une cérémonie du 19
mars de me retrouver dans le chef-lieu
du département dont je suis l'élu
à une cérémonie qui avait lieu le soir
il n'y avait aucune
lumière aucun drapeau et nous avons
déposé les gerbes dans l'ombre dans la
nuit et
puis je me suis rendu compte peu à peu
parcourant les villages les
communes que cette date du 19 mars
elle s'était peu à peu peut
imposer comme le
signe de
rassemblement de beaucoup je sais bien
pas
tous ceux qui ont combattu parce que la
République leur avait demandé de le
faire et je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait là un signe
identitaire qui d'ailleurs dans mon
département le Loiré est éta reconnu par
de nombreux élus qu'il fussent de droite
de gauche ou du centre des
sénateurs tout particulièrement qui ont
siégé ici dans cette enceinte et
beaucoup d'autres
élu et j'ai eu le sentiment assistant
depuis 31 ans à tellement de débats sur
les dates qu'une réalité s'était imposée
qui était celle d'une génération
et qu'il fallait tout simplement la
reconnaître chacun sait bien que la date
du 5 décembre ne correspond pas et
monsieur nerry l'a dit avec
éloquence un moment
historique puisque c'est la date qui qui
a correspondu aux disponibilité du
président de la République de l'époque
pour aller
inaugurer la date du 5
décembre pour aller inaugurer
un monument et je dois vous dire parlant
ainsi le respect très grand qui est le
mien pour les archis je me rends à
toutes les réunions avec les arquis il y
a eu beaucoup d'injustice à leur égard
beaucoup et je le dis de la même manière
et si vous le permettez avec le même
cœur et avec la même sincérité de même
qu'il est vrai qu'après le 19 mars il y
a eu des morts et des morts douloureuses
d'ailleurs est-il de morts qui ne le
soit pas dans de telles
circonstances comme ce fut le cas
d'ailleurs après les armistices pour les
autres
conflits alors j'ai annoncé que je
voterai
cette proposition de loi parce que je
suis intimement persuadé après avoir
participé à des centaines de réunions
mettre rendu dans tous les villages dans
toutes les communes que ça correspond à
une réalité profonde et je voulais pour
finir vous apporter cet ultime
témoignage dimanche
dernierétais dans la commune de château
neuf sur Loire dans le Loiré dans cette
commune il y a un monument aux morts sur
la place de la ville comme dans les
36700 commune de France il y a eu trois
morts lors de la guerre d'Algérie
dans cette commune issue de cette
commune et figurez-vous que la plaque où
était inscrit les trois noms figurés au
Verseau du monument au mort derrière de
l'autre
côté comme si on ne voulait pas
reconnaître leur mort leur sacrifice
comme les autres et dimanche dernier mes
chers collègues je vous dis la vérité
vous pouvez vérifier j'ai assisté à
cette cérémonie très émouvante devant 50
drapeaux avec la population qui était là
les représentants des anciens
combattants
ou à la suite de l'initiative prise par
le Maire Monsieur lois Lamoine et le
conseil municipal unanime on a déplacé
cette plaque pour la mettre devant le
monument aux morts à côté de ceux qui
sont tombés
en 141 en 39 45 et nous devons cet
hommage à tout cela et c'est dans cet
esprit monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues que je voterai ce
texte bien je vous remercie monsieur
Sueur la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Philippe
ctenbach
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
un débat qui est très long très riche
et si beaucoup de choses ont été dites
dans ce débat je crois bien que cela
montre que l'Algérie continue encore à
déchaîner les passions et 50 ans après
les passions sont toujours là c'est vrai
que pendant longtemps on a cherché à
occulter les faits pour apaiser pour
éviter de réouvrir les blessures mais on
se rend compte que 50 ans après
malheureusement certains cherchent
toujours à diviser et utilisent cette
proposition de loi portée par notre
collègue nie qui vise à rassembler pour
en faire un enjeu politicien je crois
que malheureusement on se rend compte
que ce n'est pas en niant les faits
historiques que l'on apaise et qu'il y a
un moment où il faut regarder l'histoire
en face c'est vrai que François mitaran
disait qu'il faut laisser du temps au
temps il avait bien raison mais est-ce
que 50 ans ce n'est pas suffisant parce
qu'en effet cela fait 50 ans que la
guerre d'Algérie s'est terminée il a
fallu 37 ans pour enfin reconnaître que
c'était une véritable guerre
reconnaissons 50 ans après qu'elle a
pris fin le 19 mars 1962 c'est la fin
officielle de la guerre bien évidemment
comme dans tous les conflits comme dans
tous les conflits il y a eu des morts
après mais c'est à cette date que
l'armée française a cessé les hostilités
officiellement contre la fln et c'est à
cette date que nous devons rendre
hommage aux appelés aux soldats qui ont
combattu parce que si nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui et si nous débattons c'est
avant tout pour rendre justice aux
anciens combattants ce sont eux qui
réclament depuis 50 ans cette date du 19
mars
1962 alors j'ai bien compris que
aujourd'hui le débat se focalisait sur 5
décembre et 19 mars mais reconnaissons
que depuis de nombreuses années les
anciens combattants se rassemblent le 19
mars qu'ils sont nombreux le 19 mars
qu'il y a un nombre incalculable de rue
de place qui porte le nom de cessfeu en
Algérie 19 mars 62 et pour ma part je
n'en connais pas qui porte la date du 5
décembre mais peut-être il y en a-t-il
on voit bien aussi dans nos départements
que lors des manifestations et bien le
19 mars il y a beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de drapeaux beaucoup d'anciens
combattants beaucoup d'élus et que le 5
décembre il n'y a pas fou dans les
manifestations j'ai l'impression que nos
concitoyens ont choisi un peu avec leurs
pieds quelle date ils voulaient pour
commémorer la GRE d'Algérie alors je
crois que nous sommes réunis pour
choisir une date qui
fasse qui fasse consensus qui permette
de
rassembler qui permettent de rassembler
largement le monde combattant le 5
décembre ça a été dit est une simple
date de convenance choisie pour
inaugurer le Mémorial du kbranli par
Jacques Chirac elle n'a aucune
signification historique et elle est
même vécu par un comme un affront par
beaucoup d'anciens combattants nous
sommes ici pour leur rendre hommage nous
sommes ici pour pour rendre hommage à la
trè à la 3è génération du feu ils
attendent depuis 50 ans il est temps je
crois aujourd'hui de symboliser la fin
de la GU d'Algérie par cette date du 19
mars nous sommes là pour leur rendre cet
hommage après 50 ans de passion essayons
d'avoir une position qui soit
rationnelle qui soit objective qui soit
historique et qui apaise évitons donc de
réouvrir toutes ces tensions moi je
voterai en faveur de cette proposition
parce que cela fait longtemps que dans
ma commune je suis présent le mars que
je sais que les anciens combattants sont
là qu'ils attendent qu'ils sont nombreux
à attendre notre vote et donc je crois
que nous devons leur rendre hommage et
que nous devons voter cette proposition
pour qu'il puisse enfin être honoré le
19 mars de chaque année
merci je vous remercie monsieurb la
parole est à Monsieur Louis ngre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur chers
collègues je voudrais m'opposer à cette
proposition de loi et cet article 1er en
me basant sur deux points premier point
sur la forme et
l'opportunité le 19 mars nous l'avons
dit est la date d'un divorce douloureux
pour la tion qui peut le contester
personne sur tous les bancs tout le
monde le constate pour une petite
minorité deux associations vous allez
blesser inutilement des centaines de
milliers de
Français pourquoi en cet instant
soulever une question qui divise alors
même que la France vit une
situation économique et sociale
dramatique avec plus de 3 million de
chômeurs de fermeture de dizaines
d'entreprises le rapport Gallois le
rapport du FMI explique qu'il y a le feu
à la
maison il faudrait à cet instant chers
collègues il faudrait une union
nationale il faudrait Obama le dit dans
son discours de remerciement il dit il
faut retrousser phomange travailler dur
sa situation est meilleure que la France
voilà ce que lui dit et nous nous nous
occupons d'une PPL sur le 19 mars
pendant ce temps pendant qu'il y a le
feu à la
maison en cette période difficile pour
la France cette proposition de loi me
paraît totalement inopportune sur le
fond vous voulez dites-vous rassembler
réconcilier apaiser mais votre propre
rapporteur dit lui-même j'ai noté on n
pas de raison d'être fier de ces accords
déviants qui ont conduit au massacre de
dizaines de milliers de arquis monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez raison et ici et
ici nous le savons nous constatons que
la désunion la discussion et âpre
houleuse et remplie d'émotion dans ce
hémicycle là je constate que des
citoyens manifestent dans la rue je
constate que plus de 50 associations
s'opposent à cette date je constate que
la nation est divisée et
malheureuse sur ce point on a entendu
deux de nos collègues employer le mot
malaise sur le banc de la majorité
sénatoriale et sur le ban de
l'opposition et notre collègue René
garek a livré un témoignage vécu avec
une voix brisée par émotion vous en êtes
tous témoins c'est donc la confirmation
que la cicatrice est toujours ouverte
c'est vrai plus de 50 ans après on
aurait pu espérer autre chose ce n'est
pas le cas le 19 mars chers collègues le
cesser le feu n'a pas été selon la
formule déjà employée le CC le sang la
PL est toujours là elle n'est toujours
pas refermée et vous le savez c'est un
constat c'est une réalité
la position même de votre Ministre de
votre
gouvernement qui ne soutient pas
explicitement cette PPL socialiste nous
confirme que cette date historique
dites-vous est en fait une date de
division voire de provocation à l'égard
de centaines de milliers de français
ancien combattant rapatriés archis alors
chers collègues même si vous avez la
majorité
ayez la sagesse de tous je dis bien de
tous les présidents de la République y
compris François miteran qui ayant en
charge l'intérêt supérieur de la France
et du rassemblement des Français non'ont
jamais eux voulu accepter la date du 19
mars pourquoi chers collègues pourquoi
vouloir passer en force pourquoi chers
collègues pourquoi vouloir imposer et la
discussion ici montre que vous voulez
imposer une date historique peut-être
mais qui divise certainement les
Français respectez les gens qui
souffrent toujours au plus profond de
même parce que comme l'a dit notre
collègue tout à l'heure Marie Joassin
c'est pas uniquement un problème de date
et vous le savez c'est un problème qui
concerne des centaines de milliers de
Français chers collègues quand vous
allez dans ces associations et que vous
voyez les gens qui se réunissent ils
sont heureux il va y avoir un déjeuner
il y a une bonne ambiance et les gens
pleurent chers collègues et bien quand
on voit ça on se dit moi qui ne suis pas
rapatrié moi qui ai eu la chance de ne
pas faire la guerre d'Algérie on se dit
qu'à ce moment-là notre mission à nous
de parlementaires de sénateurs c'est de
rassembler pas de diviser et cette date-
là malheureusement chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur
divise vous n'aurez pas l'apaisement que
vous dites chercher si par malheur 19
mars devait être accepté la majorité
sénatoriale diminuerait peut-être les
tensions avec l'Algérie mais aggraverait
les nôtres en France alors je demande
solennellement au nom de tous ceux qui
pleurent encore et toujours à
l'évocation de cette date de retirer
cette proposition de loi je merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur Joël
guerillot monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre mesdames m chers collègues
sénateurs et
sénatrices je n'ai pas vécu ces
événements d'Algérie puisque je suis né
pendant cette période et j'ai découvert
finalement qu'il existait un clivage sur
une date le fameux 19 mars lorsque
j'étais lu maire en
1995 alors je me demande si j'ai
vraiment le pouvoir de l'historien qui
décidera quelle est la bonne date ce que
je constate c'est que depuis
1995 je vois des anciens combattants
d'Algérie qui considère que le 19 mars
c'est bien la date du cement et du
souvenir qu'il souhaite adopter et
autour de laquelle il souhait se réunir
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je je
respecte complètement ce devoir de
mémoire et je participe à leur côté à
cette
commémoration mais j'entends aussi
d'autres et je pense que le débat
quiouvre à nous aujourd'hui le démontre
j'entends d'autres qui me disent mais
non surtout pas le 19 mars les arguments
ont été largement développés ce matin
par un certain nombre de sénateurs et
sénatrice et d'autres arguments j'ai
reçu pas plus tard qu'hier une
délégation sur cette question et ils
m'ont présenté un te parce que je leuri
demandé je leur dit mais est-ce que ce
19 mars pourrait finalement être la date
de rassemblement ils m'ont répondu
absolument pas noublion pas que 45
associations se sont jointes à l'idée
que ça ne pouvait pas être une date de
rassemblement donc mes chers collègues
c'est effectivement le 19 mars Ctait une
meilleure date que le 5 décembre c'est
avec enthousiasme que je me joindrai au
vote du 19 mars mais je le constate ce
n'est pas le cas c'est pas mieux que le
5 décembre et donc finalement faut-il
prendre cette décision alors même que le
Parlement a déjà débattu et ça serait la
troisième fois que nous reviendrons sur
cette question de date pourquoi cet
exercice pourquoi sommes-nous capables
de faire mieux que ce que d'autres ont
fait avant nous à quel intérêt
avons-nous de revenir sur dans
l'hémicycle pour ce ce débat là sinon
pour continuer à appliquer une situation
qui est une situation division je
demandais à cette délégation que j'ai
reçu hier je leur demandais mais est-ce
que vous viendrez le 19 mars si le 19
mars devenait effectivement la date la
date nationale celle qui est arrêtée la
date officielle est-ce que vous viendrez
à cette commémoration il me répondait
non et ils m'ont montré une chose ils
m'ont dit tenez prenez ce timbre ils
m'ont montré un timbre qui est un timbre
algérien qui porte le nom 19 mars
victoire de l'Algérie sur la France ils
me disent nous ne pourrons pas nous
rendre devant le monument au mort parce
que nous aurons le sentiment d'une
humiliation donc nous voyons bien que
nous sommes là dans une véritable
division et cette division nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas la prendre en
considération c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense que c'est un ce n'est
pas une bonne chose que de revenir sur
ce sujet parce que il n'est pas le fruit
d'une concertation préalable qui est
arrivé à un accord national de
l'ensemble du monde combattant et parce
que l'ensemble du monde combattant ne se
retrouve pas dans cette date-là je pense
que nous n'avons pas à faire le devoir
d'un historien de décider pourquoi il
serait meilleur cette date ou une autre
date et je pense aussi aux morts du
Maroc de Tunisie d'indchine et à tous
ceux qui finalement ne se retrouveront
pas non plus dans une date qui n'est pas
la leheure voilà la raison pour laquelle
je suis pour la suppression de ce enfin
pour l'amendement qui est de de
suppression de l'article 1er qui vient
d'être
présenter voilà pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi socialiste qui fait
du 19 mars une journée nationale du
souvenir de la guerre d'Algérie et des
combats en Tunisie ou au Maroc nous y
reviendrons plus largement dans notre
journal de 19h un journal présenté par
Delphine Girard bonne matinée à tous sur
public
sénna